[Music]
hello guys welcome to this Six Sigma
full course video by simply learn in
this video we'll cover everything you'll
need to know about Six Sigma and cover
the major concepts of lean Six Sigma we
will start out with an animated video
covering each of these Concepts and go
into more detail on the dmeic process we
will also cover the different Six Sigma
belts and much more so without further
Ado let's jump right into it before we
do that don't forget to get subscribed
to our YouTube channel and don't forget
to hit that Bell icon so that you can
never miss an update from Simply learn
now over to our training experts imagine
you've been with a really important
project at work the company you're
working for produces luxury cars the
production numbers are going down and a
lesser number of cars are getting
manufactured each day there also seems
to be an issue with the quality of the
windshield wipers that go on these cars
the question you are faced with is there
a way for the company to stop the stall
in production and increase the
production per day from one thousand to
two thousand also is there a way to find
out what's causing the drop in the wiper
quality there is Six Sigma Six Sigma
gives you the tools and techniques to
determine what's making the
manufacturing process slow down how you
can eliminate the delays improve the
process and fix further issues along the
way the concept was introduced in 1980
by Bill Smith while working for Motorola
since then Six Sigma has seen worldwide
adoption Six Sigma aims to reduce the
time defects and variability experienced
by processes in an organization thanks
to Six Sigma you can produce an effect
free product
99.996 percent of the time allowing only
3.4 errors per 1 million opportunities
Six Sigma also increases Customer
Loyalty towards the brand improves
employee morale leading to higher
productivity Six Sigma has two major
methodologies dmaic and dmadv let's look
at the first methodology
dmaic is an acronym for Define measure
analyze improve and control let's have a
look at each of these stages
individually and how it relates to your
earlier problem in the Define phase you
determine what issues you're facing
what's your opportunities for
improvement are and what the customer
requires of you here you look at the
process as a whole and determine the
issues with the manufacturing process in
this case finding out why the cars had
varying windshield wiper quality and how
to optimize the current process to
manufacture more cars in the measure
phase you determine how the process is
performing currently in its unaltered
state you determine the current number
of cars that are manufactured in a day
in the current scenario 1000 cars are
manufactured in a day and each of these
cars are outfitted with a pair of
windshield wipers by one of 30 machines
used some of the metrics measured or how
many cars are produced in a day time
taken to assemble a car how many
windshield wipers were attached in a day
time that takes them to do so defects
detected from each machine on assembly
completion and so on following this in
the analyze phase you determine what
caused the defect or variation on
analyzing previous data you find out
that one of the machines that installed
the windshield wiper was not performing
as well as it was supposed to production
was taking longer since the car chassis
was being moved across the different
locations slower as cranes had to
individually pick and drop the frame
this was because the wheels were
attached to the car only in the last
stage next in the improved phase you
make changes to the manufacturing
process and ensure the defects are
addressed
to replace the faulty machines that
installed the windshield wiper with
another one you also find a way to save
time by attaching Wheels on the frame in
the initial stages of the manufacturing
process unlike how it was done earlier
now the car can be moved across the
assembly area faster and finally in the
control phase you make regular
adjustments to control new processes and
future Performance Based on the changes
made the company was able to reduce
production time and manufacture about 2
000 cars a day with a higher quality of
output dmaic is one of the most commonly
used methodologies in the world it
focuses on improving the existing
products of the organization the second
methodology is dmadv which is short for
Define measure analyze design and verify
it is used when the company has to
create a new product or service from
scratch it is also called dfss or design
for Six Sigma
let's take the scenario where the
company decides to build a new model a
sports car in the Define phase you
define the requirements of the customer
based on inputs from customers
historical data industry research you
determine what you need to ensure your
car becomes a success the data collected
indicates customers are drawn to cars
which can achieve more than 150 miles
per hour customers are also more
inclined towards cars which have V6
engines and an aerodynamic frame then in
the measure phase you use the customer's
requirements to create a specification
this specification helps Define the
product in a measurable method Ace you
analyze the product to determine whether
there are better ways to achieve the
desired results areas of improvement are
determined and tested based on the
analysis of the Prototype created in
this phase you find that the product
satisfies just about all of the customer
requirements except the top speed
so research begins on an aluminum alloy
that could possibly meet the speed
requirements of the customer following
this the design phase based on the
learnings from the analysis phase the
new process or product is designed
revisions are made to the model and the
car is manufactured with the new
material the analysis phase is repeated
based on the new design you also bring a
focus group and see how they receive it
based on their feedback further changes
are made and finally in the verify phase
you check whether the end result meets
or exceeds customer requirements once
you launch your brand new sports car you
collect customer feedback and
incorporate it into future designs and
guess what your customers are loving the
new design and that is dmadv for you Six
Sigma has also found success in a number
of different Industries the
petrochemical healthcare banking
government and software are some of the
industries that have utilized the
concepts of Six Sigma to achieve their
business goals another commonly used
methodology adopted by companies around
the world is lean lean is a methodology
that aims to remove any part of the
process but does not bring value to the
customer it means doing more with less
while doing it better the philosophy
behind lean comes from the Japanese
manufacturing industry by Bob Hartman
who at the time was part of Toyota since
then across the world services and
Manufacturing organizations have
Incorporated lean within their
businesses but what if you could have
the best of both worlds a combination of
both Six Sigma and Lane that's lean Six
Sigma before we get into lean Six Sigma
we've got a quiz for you what
methodology is used by companies when
they want to release a new product
created from scratch a design measure
analyze Define verify B Define measure
analyze design verify
C demand measure analyze improve control
D Define measure analyze improve control
leave your answers in the comments
section below for a chance to be one of
three people to win an Amazon voucher
now let's get back to lean Six Sigma
lean Six Sigma is a methodology that
focuses on eliminating problems removing
inefficiencies in waste while improving
the working conditions to ensure the
customer's needs are better satisfied it
combines the tools methods and
principles of lean and Six Sigma while
another video detailing the process of
lean Six Sigma very soon imagine you're
the manager of a supermarket chain
you've noticed that two things need your
immediate attention the first issue is
how to handle the different kinds of
ways that you encounter at your
supermarket
the next one requires you to address the
supply chain issues at the supermarket
which are causing delays to the morning
delivery of milk
leading to customer dissatisfaction and
attrition these problems can be solved
by incorporating two of the most popular
quality management methodologies in the
world lean and Six Sigma one famous for
its ability to handle waste and another
known for process Improvement
but what if there was a methodology that
combined the concepts of both Six Sigma
and Link one that can solve all your
issues well there is lean Six Sigma
before we dive into lean Six Sigma let's
take a closer look at its parent
methodologies
first off lean is a methodology that
focuses on providing value to the
customer
eliminating waste continuous Improvement
reducing cycle time lean in Six Sigma
both aim to handle waste but what is
this waste waste is any step or action
in the process that a user does not gain
any value from in short things that
users wouldn't want to pay for
why would a consumer want to pay extra
for the additional truck that was
required to deliver milk to the
supermarket just because the other one
broke down
this waste can be divided into eight
categories let's have a look at each of
them One Transportation this waste
refers to the excess movement of people
tools inventory equipment and other
components of a process then it is
required materials then required this
can cause damage and defects to products
or materials greater time for completion
inefficient allocation of capital and so
on
three motion this refers to the time and
effort wasted due to unnecessary
movement of people equipment or
Machinery this could be sitting through
inventory double data entry and so on
4. waiting this can be time wasted
waiting on information instructions
materials or equipment
five overproduction this is the waste
created due to producing more products
than required
six over processing it refers to more
work more components or more steps in a
product or service than required
7. defects this is the waste originating
from a product or service that fails to
meet customer expectations eight skills
this waste refers to the waste of human
potential under utilizing capabilities
and delegating tasks to people with
inadequate training
for years now many systems have emerged
that use the lean methodology to
identify and handle the different kinds
of waste some of the more popular and
effective ones are jit or just in time
5s and kanman
the jit methodology focuses on reducing
the amount of time the production system
takes to provide an output and the
response time from suppliers to
customers 5S is another methodology that
focuses on cleanliness in organization
while improving profits and efficiency
kanban is also another popular
methodology to achieve Lane
it is a visual method to manage tasks
and workflows
kanban enables users visualize the
workflow to identify issues in the
process and fix them
these methodologies help in optimizing
the waste production and are often used
together to maximize results
so that's the first problem solved now
let's have a look at how you can improve
the supermarket supply chain efficiency
for that let's have a look at the other
part of lean Six Sigma Six Sigma
Six Sigma is a set of tools and
techniques that are used for process
Improvement and removing defects let's
see how Six Sigma makes that possible
Six Sigma has two major methodologies
dmaic and dmadv
you can learn more about these two
methodologies by checking out our Six
Sigma in nine minutes video by clicking
on the top right corner let's have a
closer look at dmaic since lean Six
Sigma uses the dmaic methodology of Six
Sigma dmaic is an acronym for Define
measure analyze improve control it is
used to improve existing products and
processes so that it can meet the
customer's requirements
in the Define phase you determine what
the goals of the project are in this
case you want to reduce the amount of
time taken to deliver milk from the
warehouse to the supermarket so that it
is stocked on the supermarket shelves
before 8 30 in the morning
in the measure phase you measure the
performance of the current unaltered
process the milk truck leaves at 7 30
a.m in the morning and can take one of
three routes a b and c route a is
currently the preferred one as it takes
only 60 Minutes to reach the supermarket
compared to the routes B and C which
takes 70 and 80 minutes respectively
in the analyze phase you find out why
the defects exist since routes B and C
were school bus routes by reducing the
starting time by one hour at 6 30
instead of 7 30 meant avoiding the
traffic routes B and C now take 40 to 45
minutes to reach the supermarket route a
still takes the milk truck one hour to
get to the supermarket even when the
truck leaves at 6 30 am
in the improve phase performance can be
improved by addressing and eliminating
the root causes
now that you've realized that advancing
the milk pickup by an hour and changing
the route to Route B can save time you
change the process accordingly providing
your workers with ample time to stock
the milk into the shelves before the
morning rush and finally in the control
phase you make regular adjustments to
control new processes and future
performance
you continue to monitor the delivery
times and try out alternate routes to
continually improve the process and
ensure even faster delivery
this process change LED to reduced man
hours and cost enhanced cells and
customer retention
the lean Six Sigma methodology offers
many such benefits to businesses let's
take a look at some of them one increase
in profits two standardized and
simplified process three reduced errors
4. employee development five value to
customers and that is lean Six Sigma for
you 6 Sigma is a set of tools and
techniques that have helped several
companies around the world achieve
business success hi guys I'm Rob from
Simply learn and let's get started with
our introduction to Six Sigma now let's
understand this better with an example
here let's talk about how things were
before Six Sigma was introduced here
Jenny and James are having a
conversation with each other Jenny is
James's manager and she's not happy at
all she says James is in a lot of
trouble this is because she found out
that the customers weren't happy with
the organization's service and the
operational costs were way too high and
as manager James had to make sure that
this did not happen now let's have a
look at the same scenario in present day
here we have Jenny congratulating James
she's very impressed with his work but
James says it's all thanks to Six Sigma
methodology so Jenny asks she wants to
know more about Six Sigma so to
understand Six Sigma here's what you
need to know firstly we'll have to
understand what is Six Sigma what its
advantages are some of its methodologies
what are the different roles in a Six
Sigma Team Water slain what is a lean
process and and what is lean Six Sigma
so now let's get started with
understanding what exactly is Six Sigma
the Six Sigma methodology makes sure to
find as well as eliminate any sort of
defect or variation that could be
affecting your product service or
process now this methodology is
statistics based is data driven and
focused on continuous Improvement now
this means that there's no end goal in
the Horizon there's always another goal
to reach there are three core ideologies
behind Six Sigma the first one states
that for any business to be successful
there is continuous efforts that are
required so that you can achieve stable
as well as predictable process results
the second ideology states that in any
business or manufacturing process there
are certain characteristics that can be
defined measured analyzed and controlled
the final ideology says that along with
the rest of the organization the top
level management plays a very important
role to making sure that they sustained
quality now let's talk about the
advantages of Six Sigma Six Sigma can
help produce a road map or a path
through which you can easily find and
reduce any sort of organizational risk
and reduce the operational costs another
Advantage is that it helps improve the
efficiency of the process and making
sure that it works in a timely manner it
decreases defects improves the overall
tracking and monitoring process and
ensures that the products are aligned
with the company's policies it is also
reported that it greatly helps improve
customer as well as vendor satisfaction
it helps improve the cash flow and
ensures that the products are complying
with the regulations of the organization
now let me tell you about the process of
Six Sigma now Six Sigma projects are of
basically two methodologies the dmaic
and the dma DV now let's talk about
dmaic in detail that's short for Define
measure analyze improve and control this
is one of the most commonly used
methodologies in the world this is
commonly used by companies when they
have to fix or improve an already
existing product or process that does
not meet the company's standards now
let's have a look at the process first
phase is the Define phase in this phase
you define the problem that the
customers are facing you find out where
you can improve and you clearly
understand what the customers require of
you the second phase is the measure
phase now in this phase you actually
identify how well the process is doing
in its current unaltered state in the
analyze phase you process the data that
you get from the measure phase and
determine what exactly is the cost of
the delay or variation in the improve
phase you start by making small changes
to the business process and make sure
that the problem you identified earlier
is being taken care of and finally in
the control phase you control the new
process so that it doesn't go wrong and
use the same knowledge for future
processes now let's have a look at dmadv
this is short for Define measure analyze
design and verify now this is also
commonly known as dfss or the design for
Six Sigma now this is commonly used by
companies around the world when they
have a new product that needs to be
created all the way from scratch in the
first phase which is the defined phase
you define what the goal of the project
is and what the customers require of you
in the measure phase you measure as well
as determine what the customer needs and
how they respond to your products in the
analyze phase you perform analyzes to
determine how you can improve your
product or service so they can better
serve your customers in the design phase
you set up process details and make
optimizations to the design to make sure
your customer is satisfied and finally
in the verify phase you check how well
the design is working out and how well
it meets the customer's needs now before
we go on let's talk about how Six Sigma
was used in reference to the earlier
example the situation that James was
facing a survey conducted by the
organization James was working for
indicated that the customers weren't
very happy with the organization so they
decided to fix that with the help of Six
Sigma so they decided that the dmaic
methodology would be best suited to
solve their problem so let's have a look
at what they did firstly in the Define
phase they used a tool called the voice
of the customer this tool represented
the needs as well as requirements of the
customer this showed that the customers
expected prompt delivery the correct
product selection and a knowledgeable
distribution team from the company and
now on to the measure phase the company
wanted to know why the customers didn't
like them so they performed some data
collection from there they found out
that they took 56 percent longer than
other companies to deliver their product
so they decided to reduce the amount of
time it takes between order entry and
the delivery of the product and now in
the analyze phase here they knew what
the issue was but they wanted to know
what exactly made their products
delivery so slow why were the customers
receiving the products relate then they
performed some analysis their analysis
showed the possible causes it could have
been inaccurate sales plans issues with
their safety stock issues with their
vendors delivery performance and falling
behind on the manufacturing schedule
further analysis also indicated that
most of their sales almost 80 percent
came from 30 percent of their product
products the issue was that they didn't
have enough Safety stock to satisfy the
customers who required that 30 percent
of products and now on to the improve
phase so now that they knew what was
causing their problem they wanted to
solve it they began to have monthly
reviews and try to make sure that their
in-demand products stayed in demand
another thing that they wanted to focus
on was to make sure that they could
order and provide the customer with the
products that they wanted and finally
onto the control phase they began to set
up plans so that they could monitor the
sales of that 30 percent of products
that were selling the most each year
they would review how well a product was
selling and replace it if it had fallen
out of favor now let me tell you what
Six Sigma team consists of let's talk
about the roles in a Six Sigma team
first up is level seven now these are
individuals who are at the novice level
now these individuals don't know in
great detail about what the project is
but they have a basic understanding of
the principles and the methodology
behind the program now they usually
support with smaller projects and with
smaller issues but these individuals
found the foundation for the people who
decide where the program is going and
now we're at level 6. now these are
individuals who have a yellow Belt
certification now they're core members
of the Six Sigma team who have an
understanding of how the basic metrics
work and how they can perform some sort
of improvement now they have their own
areas of expertise and they're required
to determine certain processes that need
to improve at the same time they're also
in charge of smaller Improvement
projects now level five these are people
who have a Green Belt certification now
these individuals are usually part-time
professionals who have a number of
different duties to fulfill they focus
on smaller Six Sigma projects they are
usually involved with Gathering data
performing some sort of experiment and
analyzing information they also assist
with black belt projects and now we're
at level 4. these are individuals who
have a Black Belt certification they
usually team leaders of a Six Sigma
project they complete four to six
projects a year and are experts in the
principle people's methodologies and
lean Concepts thanks to their
understanding of statistical
experimental design they can also
understand the hidden reasons behind why
a particular product failed and now
we're at level 3 these are individuals
who have a master Black Belt
certification now these are individuals
who are experts when it comes to
resources the practices and the
methodologies that are employed in Six
Sigma their main emphasis is to coach
train and certify black belts they also
are involved with other Six Sigma
leaders to ensure a company's goals are
met now level 2 these individuals are
called Champions so they work really
closely with the executives and usually
have a role like a senior or a middle
executive level role they also have a
clear understanding of what exactly is
the company's vision and Mission they
also understand metrics so that they can
set up a Six Sigma project that lines up
with the company's goals they're
responsible for removing any sort of
Roadblock that could hamper the success
of a project and finally we are at level
one these are the the executives now
these individuals represent the highest
level when it comes to a Six Sigma team
now they have training as well as
experience through which they can set up
Six Sigma projects that clearly line up
with the company's goals their main
emphasis is to ensure that the project
is able to add value to the organization
and at the end of the day is successful
now this is when Jenny interjects she
wants to know about lean John tells her
that lean just like sex Sigma is another
methodology so what exactly is lean now
lean is a methodology that has a very
important ideology to make sure that
this continuous optimization of the
processes and there's an elimination of
waste so what's waste so waste is
basically any part of the process that
the customer doesn't want to pay for it
is a process that does not add any value
to the customer now coming back to lean
here are some of its characteristics
whenever decisions are being made in a
lean team the main emphasis is to
understand how it exactly adds value to
the customer every remember in a lean
team has a clear understanding of what
exactly are the goals of the
organization it also encourages
employers to push for further success
even if the organization isn't a good
place or is already doing well there's
also an emphasis on cross-functional
collaboration and communication lean
focuses on answering the difficult
question or the complex ones rather than
employing short-term fixes and with lean
you can easily prepare for issues that
can come up in the future or improvise
in unexpected circumstances so let's
talk about how lean and Six Sigma are
different from one another the lean
methodology aims to reduce waste it does
so by analyzing the workflow it also
emphasizes on minimizing resource usage
and improving customer value now let's
talk about Six Sigma the aim of Six
Sigma is to provide near perfect results
it wants to reduce costs and improve
customer satisfaction basically both of
them are moving towards the same goal to
reduce the amount of waste and to create
efficient processes now let's talk about
the process of lean now there are five
different steps let's start with the
first one identifying value you need to
identify value by determining what
exactly is the problem you're trying to
solve for the customer the second step
is to map your value stream you need to
map the workflow of your company you
need to focus on the different actions
and the people that are involved with
the process you need to be able to
identify which parts of the process are
able to add value and the ones that
don't the third step is to create a flow
you need to break up your work into
smaller silos and visualize the workflow
so that you can easily identify problems
that might show up later the next step
is to establish pull you need to set up
a system through which products are
created only when there is a demand or a
requirement for it through this you can
optimize resource capacity and finally
we're at the fifth step which is
continuous Improvement you need to
ensure all your employees at all levels
are involved in the continuous
Improvement of the process so what
exactly is lean Six Sigma what is if you
could combine The Best of Both Worlds
the combination of Six Sigma and lean
methodology led to the creation of lean
Six Sigma lean Six Sigma is a
methodology that aims to solve problems
removes any form of waste or
inefficiency and improving the working
conditions of employees to make sure
that they can serve the customers better
now this is a combination of the tools
methods and principles that are employed
in lean and Six Sigma let's talk about
some of its advantages it aims to
provide customers with a better
experience by streamlining the process
with efficient power flows it aims to
drive higher results it can reduce cost
remove waste and prevent effects it can
help the organization handle day-to-day
problems the decreased lead times help
increase capacity in profitability and
finally it helps with people development
and improving the morale of the
organization
this lesson provides an overview of the
Certified Six Sigma Green Belt or cssgb
course
a process is a series of steps designed
to produce a product and or service
according to the requirement of the
customer
a process mainly consists of four parts
input process steps output and feedback
input is something put into a process or
expended in its operation to achieve an
output or a result
for example man material machine and
management
output is the final product delivered to
an internal or external customer for
example product or services
it is important to understand that if
the output of a process is an input for
another process the latter process is
the internal customer
each input can be classified as
controllable represented as C
non-controllable represented as NC noise
represented as n and critical
represented as X
the most important aspect of the process
is the feedback
as can be inferred from the image any
change in the inputs causes change in
the output
therefore y equals f of x
feedback helps in process control
because it suggests changes to the
inputs
let us learn about the process of Six
Sigma in the next screen
let us understand how Six Sigma Works in
this screen
sex Sigma is successful because of the
following reasons sex Sigma is a
management strategy it creates an
environment where the management
supports Six Sigma as a business
strategy and not as a standalone
approach or a program to satisfy some
public relations need
Six Sigma mainly emphasizes the DMACC
method of problem solving
Focus teams are assigned well-defined
projects that directly influence the
organization's bottom line with customer
satisfaction and increased quality being
byproducts
6 Sigma also requires extensive use of
statistical methods
the next screen will focus on some key
terms used in Six Sigma
let us look at the segment level chart
in this screen
as discussed earlier the Six Sigma
quality means 3.4 defects in 1 million
opportunities or process with a
99.9966 percent yield
the sigma level chart given on the
screen shows the values for other Sigma
levels please take a look at the values
carefully
let us understand the benefits of Six
Sigma in the next screen
the organizational benefits of Six Sigma
are as follows a Six Sigma process
eliminates the root cause of problems
and defects in a process
sometimes the solution is creating
robust products and services that
mitigate the impact of a variable input
or output on a customer's experience for
example many Electrical Utility Systems
have voltage variability up to and
sometimes exceeding a 10 percent
deviation from nominal value thus most
electrical products are built to
tolerate the variability drawing more
amperage without damage to any
components or the unit itself
using Six Sigma reduces variation in a
process and thereby reduces waste in a
process
it ensures customer satisfaction and
provides process standardization
rework is substantially reduced because
one gets it right the very first time
further Six Sigma addresses the key
business requirement
Six Sigma can also be used by
organizations to gain advantage and
become world leaders in their respective
fields ultimately the whole Six Sigma
process is to satisfy customers and
Achieve organizational goals in the next
screen let us understand Six Sigma and
quality
taking a process to Six Sigma level
ensures that the quality of the product
is maintained the primary goal of
improved quality is increased profits
for the organization
in very simple terms quality is defined
as the degree of Excellence of a product
or a service provided to the customer it
is conformance to customer requirement
if the customer is satisfied with the
product or service then the product or
service is of the required quality
let us look at the history of quality in
the next screen in the mid-1930s
statistical process control SPC was
developed by Walter schuhart and used
extensively during World War II to
quickly expand the US's industrial
capabilities
SPC is the application of statistical
techniques to control any process
water shoehart's work on the common
cause of variation and special cause of
variation assignable has been used
proactively in all Six Sigma projects
the approach to Quality has varied from
time to time in the 1960s there were
quality circles which originated in
Japan it was started by Kaoru Ishikawa
quality circles were self-improvement
groups composed of small number of
employees belonging to a single
Department
quality circles brought in improvements
with little or no help from the top
management
in 1987 ISO 9000 was introduced
ISO stands for International
Organization for standardization
ISO 9000 is a set of international
standards on quality management and
quality assurance to help organizations
Implement Quality Management Systems ISO
9000 is still in effect
baldrige award now known as the Malcolm
baldrige National Quality award was
developed by the U.S Congress in 1987 to
raise awareness of Quality Management
Systems as well as recognize and award
U.S companies that have successfully
implemented Quality Management Systems
in 1988 another quality approach was
developed known as benchmarking in this
approach an organization measures its
performance against the best
organizations in its field determines
how such performance levels were
achieved and the information is used by
the organization to improve itself
then in the 1990s there was the balance
scorecard approach it is a management
tool that helps managers of all levels
to monitor their results in their key
areas so that one metric is not
optimized while another is ignored
during the year 1996 through 1997 an
approach known as re-engineering was
developed this approach involved the
restructuring of an entire organization
and its processes integrating various
functional tasks into cross-functional
processes is one of the examples of
re-engineering
in the next screen let us find out about
the quality gurus and their contribution
to the field of quality
let us focus on Six Sigma and the
business system in this screen
business systems are designed to
implement a process or a set of
processes a business system ensures that
process inputs are at the right place
and at the right time so that each step
of the process has the resource it needs
a business system designed should be
responsible for collecting and analyzing
data so that continual Improvement of
its processes products and services is
insured a business system has processes
sub-processes and steps as it subsets
Human Resources manufacturing and
marketing are some examples of processes
in a business system
Sigma improves a business system by
continuously removing the defects in its
processes and also by sustaining the
changes a defective item is any product
or service that a customer would reject
a customer can be the user of the
ultimate product or service or can be
the next process Downstream in the
business system
let us learn about Six Sigma projects
and organizational goals in the
following screen
let us understand the structure of the
Six Sigma team in this screen there are
totally five levels in the Six Sigma
screen the first level consists of the
top Executives of the organization
these people lead change and provide
direction as they own the vision of the
organization for any Improvement
initiative to work it is important that
top management of the organization be
actively involved in its propagation the
top Executives own the Six Sigma
initiatives next in the level are Six
Sigma Champions they identify and scope
projects develop deployment and strategy
and support cultural change they also
identify and Coach master black belts
three to four Master block belts work
under every champion
Six Sigma Master black belts train and
Coach black belts green belts and
various functional leaders of the
organization
they usually have at least three to four
black belts under them the fourth level
and Six Sigma structure is Six Sigma
Black belts they apply strategies to
specific projects and lead and direct
teams to execute projects
finally there are Six Sigma Green belts
they support the black belt employees by
participating in Project teams green
belts play a dual role they work on the
project and perform day-to-day jobs
related to their work area
in the next screen we will understand
the drivers and metrics of
organizational strategy
while financial accounting is useful to
track physical assets the balanced
scorecard or BSE offers a more holistic
approach to strategy implementation and
performance measurement by taking into
account perspectives other than the
financial one
for an organization traditional
strategic activities that concentrate
only on financial metrics are not
sufficient to predict future performance
they are not sufficient to implement and
control the Strategic plan either BSC
translates the organizational strategy
into actionable objectives that can be
met on an everyday basis and provides a
framework for performance measurement
the balanced scorecard helps clarify the
organizational vision and Mission to
workable action items to be carried out
and measured it also provides feedback
on both internal business processes and
external outcomes by doing so it enables
continuous Improvement in strategic
performance toward achieving
organizational goals
the balanced scorecard achieves all this
by integrating the organizational
strategy with a limited number of key
metrics from four major areas of
performance
Finance customer relations internal
processes and learning and growth
many organizations in the world use
balanced scorecard approaches and the
number is increasing every day
in the next screen we will describe the
balanced scorecard framework we will
learn about developing a balanced
scorecard in this screen
while applying the balance scorecard in
an organization care must be taken to
account for interactions between
different perspectives or strategic
business units and avoid optimizing the
results of one at the expense of another
to outline the strategy a top-down
approach is followed by determining the
Strategic objectives measures targets
and initiatives for each perspective
the Strategic objectives refer to the
strategy to be achieved in that
perspective three or four leading
objectives are agreed upon the progress
towards strategic objectives is assessed
using specific measures these measures
should be closely related to the actual
performance drivers this enables
effectively evaluating progress
high-level metrics are linked to lower
level operational measures the target
values for each measure are set the
initiatives required to achieve the
target value are identified
as already mentioned this exercise is
carried out for all the perspectives
finally the scorecard is integrated into
the management system
in the next screen let us understand the
change in the approach to the balance
scorecard from the four Box model of BSE
to strategy Maps
in earlier approaches to the balance
scorecard the perspectives were
presented in a four Box model this kind
of scorecard was more a comprehensive
glance at the key performance indicators
or metrics in different perspectives
however the key performance indicators
or metrics of different perspectives
reviewed independent of each other which
led to a silo based approach and lack of
integration
however modern scorecards place the
focus on the interrelations between the
objectives and metrics of different
perspectives and how they support each
other
a well-designed balanced scorecard
recognizes the influence of one
perspective on another and the effect of
these interactions on organizational
strategy
to achieve the objectives in one
perspective it is necessary to achieve
the objectives in another perspective in
short the four perspectives form a chain
of cause and effect relationships
a map of interlinked objectives from
each perspective is created these
objectives represents the performance
drivers which determine the
effectiveness of strategy implementation
this is called a strategy map
the function of a strategy map is to
outline what the organization wants to
accomplish and how it plans to
accomplish it the strategy map is one
page view of how the organization can
create value
for example financial success is
dependent on giving customers what they
want which in turn depends on the
internal processes and learning and
growth at an individual level in the
next screen we will look at the impact
of the balanced scorecard on the
organization
the balance scorecard and strategy map
Force managers to consider cause and
effect relationships which leads to
better identification of key drivers and
a more rounded approach to strategic
planning the BSC enables the
organization to improve in the following
ways
being a one-page document a strategy map
can easily be communicated and
facilitates understanding at all levels
of the organization an organization is
successful in meeting its objectives
only when everyone understands the
strategy
the balance scorecard also forces an
organization to measure what really
matters and manage information better so
that quality of decision making is
higher
creating performance reports against a
balanced scorecard allows for a
structured approach to reporting
progress it also enables organizations
to create reports and dashboards to
communicate performance transparently
and meaningfully
as expected a balanced scorecard helps
an organization to better align itself
and its processes to the Strategic goals
outlined in the BSE the overall
objectives of the BSE can be cascaded
into each business unit to enable that
unit to work toward the common
organizational goal
all the activities of the organization
such as budgeting or risk management are
automatically aligned to the Strategic
objectives to conclude the balance
scorecard is a simple and Powerful tool
that when implemented correctly equips
an organization to perform better
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will look at what lean
is and how lean is applied to a process
let us start with the lane Concepts in
the next screen let us look at the
process issues in this screen
Lane focuses on three major issues in a
process known by their Japanese names
muda mura and Marie
Moda refers to non-value adding work
mura represents unevenness and Marie
represents overburden
together they represent the key aspects
in lean let us look at the types of
waste in the next screen
there are seven types of Buddha or waste
as per lean principles let us understand
these seven types of muda overproduction
this refers to producing more than is
required for example a customer needed
10 products and 12 were delivered
inventory in simple words this refers to
stock
the term inventory includes finished
goods semi-finished Goods raw materials
supplies kept in waiting and some of the
work in progress for example test
scripts waiting to be executed by the
testing team defects repairs rejects any
product or service deemed unusable by
the customer or any effort to make it
usable to the original customer or a new
customer for example errors found in the
source code of a payroll module by
quality control team motion a waste due
to poor ergonomics of the workplace for
example finance and account team sit on
the first floor but invoices to
customers are printed on the ground
floor causing unnecessary Personnel
movement
over processing additional process on a
product or service to remove unnecessary
attribute or feature is over processing
for example a customer needs a bottle
and you deliver a bottle with extra
plastic casing a customer needs abec3
bearing and your process is tuned to
produce more precise abec 7 bearings
taking more time for something the
customer doesn't need
waiting when a part waits for processing
or the operator waits for work the
wastage of waiting occurs for example
improper scheduling of Staff members
transport when the product moves
unnecessarily in the process without
adding value
for example our product is finished and
yet it travels 10 kilometers to the
warehouse before it gets shipped to the
customer another example an electronic
form is transferred to 12 people some of
them seeing the form more than once that
is the form is traveling over the same
space multiple times
next we will look at lean waste other
than the seven types of waste discussed
some lean experts talk about additional
areas of waste under utilized skills
skills are underutilized when the
workforce has capabilities that are not
being fully used toward productive
efforts people are assigned to jobs in
which they do not fit
underperforming processes automation of
poorly performing process improving a
process that should be eliminated if
possible for example the product returns
department or product discounts process
a symmetry in processes that should be
eliminated for example two signatures to
approve a cost reduction and six
signatures to reverse a cost reduction
that created higher costs in other areas
in the next screen we will look at an
exercise on identifying the waste type
we will cover each step of the lean
process in the next few screens in this
screen we will learn about the first
step identify value to implement lean to
a process it is important to find out
what the customer wants once this is
done the process should be evaluated to
identify what it needs to possess to
meet customer requirements
the next screen will focus on the next
step of the lean process value stream
mapping
in this screen we will discuss the
differences between push and pull
processes an organization can adopt
either of these processes depending on
the requirement
contrary to a pull process in a push
process the first step is to forecast
the demand for a product or service the
production line then begins to fill this
demand and produced parts are stocked in
anticipation of customer demand
for example a garments manufacturer
produces 200 shirts based on expected
demand and then waits for customer
orders for them note that the demand is
expected and not actual discounts
offered to customers by big retailers
are examples of the push process
if the Garment company adopts a pull
process instead it would start making
the shirts only after receiving a
confirmed demand from customers
note that although the poll approach
seems better it is not applicable to all
situations for example a pharmacy uses a
push process
in the next screen we will learn about
theory of constraints
let us look at an example for the TOC
methodology in this screen the three
sub-processes in the packing process are
coding or printing filling and sealing
the data for the three sub-processes are
observed and collected as number of
units produced in an hour the data is as
follows
coding or printing is 900 units per hour
filling is 720 units per hour and
ceiling is 780 units per hour
how can you implement the TOC
methodology in this example
let us build the TOC map for this
example
the first step in the TOC methodology is
to identify the constraint looking at
the data the output per hour from The
Filling process is 720. this is the
constraint in the system
in the Second Step the constraint is
exploited by analyzing the performance
using data to break the constraint a
repair and maintenance Personnel can be
assigned to maintain the filling machine
on a daily basis
in the third step the other fixes in the
repair and maintenance function are made
as subordinate decisions to the one
taken in step two in this example carry
out the maintenance of the filling
machine
in the fourth step the constraint is
elevated by implementing the decisions
in this example remove the damages from
the filling machine the next step is to
go back to step one and identify the
next system constraint as per the data
collected after implementation of the
first cycle of the TOC ceiling can be
identified as the next system constraint
let us now analyze the data before and
after Toc implementation in this example
the number of units produced per hour
before implementing the TOC encoding or
printing process was 900 units filling
process was 720 units and sealing
process was 780 units
after implementing the TOC the number of
units produced per hour for the filling
process increased to 840 from 720 units
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in this topic we will discuss the
concepts in design for Six Sigma or dfss
let us first understand dfss in the next
screen
dfss or design for Six Sigma is a
business process methodology that
ensures that any new product or service
meets customer requirements and the
process for that product or service is
already at Six Sigma level
dfss uses tools such as Quality Function
deployment or qfd and failure mode and
effects analysis or FMEA
dfss can help a business system to
introduce an entirely new product or
service for the customer
it can also be used to introduce a new
category of product or service for the
business system
for example an fmcg company plans to
make a new brand of hair oil a type of
product already in the market
dfss also improves the product or
service and adds to the current product
or service lines
to implement dfss a business system has
to know its customer requirements
dfss can be used to design a new product
or service a new process for a new
product or service or redesign of an
existing product or service to meet
customer requirements
let us learn about processes for dfss in
the next screen
the two major processes for dfss are
idov and dmadv
idov stands for identify design optimize
and verify
dmadv stands for Define measure analyze
design and verify
in the idov process the first step
involves identifying specific customer
needs based on which the new product and
business process will be designed the
next step involves design which involves
identifying functional requirements
developing alternate Concepts evaluating
the Alternatives selecting a best fit
concept and predicting Sigma capability
tools such as FMEA are used here
the third step optimize uses a
statistical approach to calculate
tolerance with respect to the desired
output
when idov is implemented to design a
process expected to work at Six Sigma
level this is checked in the optimize
phase
if the process does not meet
expectations the optimize phase helps in
developing detailed design elements
predicting performances and optimizing
design
the last stage of idov is to verify that
is to test and validate the design and
finally to check conformance to Six
Sigma standards
the other process dmadv has five stages
the first stage is to define the
customer requirements and goals for the
process product or service next measure
and match performance to customer
requirements
the third stage involves analysis and
assessment of the design for the process
product or service
the next step is to design and implement
the array of latest processes required
for the new process product or service
the final stage is to verify results and
maintain performance
in the next screen we will look at the
differences between idov and dma DB
the primary difference between idov and
dma DB is that while idov is used only
to design a new product or service
dmadb can be used to design either a new
product or service or redesign an
existing product or service
idlv involves design of a new process
while dmadv involves redesigning an
existing process in idov no analysis or
measurement of existing process is done
and the whole development is new the
design staff immediately follows the
identification of customer requirements
in contrast dmadv the existing product
service or process is examined
thoroughly before moving to the design
phase
the design stage comes only after
defining requirements and analyzing the
existing product service or process
in the following screen we will learn
about tool Quality Function deployment
or qfd which is one of the dfss tools
qfd also called voice of customer or VOC
or House of quality is a predefined
method of identifying customer
requirements it is a systematic process
to understand the needs of the customer
and convert them into a set of design
and Manufacturing requirements
qfd motivates business to focus on its
customers and design products that are
competitive in lesser time and at lesser
cost
the primary learning from qfd includes
which customer requirements are most
important what the organization's
strengths and weaknesses are where an
organization should focus their efforts
and where most of the work needs to be
done
to learn from qfd the organization
should ask relevant questions to
customers and tabulate them to bring out
a set of parameters critical to the
design of the product apart from
understanding customer requirements it
is also important to know what would
happen if a particular product or
service fails when being used by a
customer
it is necessary to understand the
effects of failure on the customer to
ensure preventive actions are taken and
to be able to answer the customers in
the event of failure
in the next screen we will look at
another dfss tool failure modes and
effects analysis or FMEA
failure modes and effects analysis or
FMEA is a preemptive tool that helps any
system to identify potential pitfalls at
all levels of a business system it helps
the organization to identify and
prioritize the different failure modes
of its product or service and what
effect the failure would have on the
customer it helps in identifying the
critical areas in a system on which the
organization's efforts can be focused
note that while FMEA enables
identification of critical areas it does
not offer solutions to the identified
problems we will look at the varieties
of FMEA such as dfmea and pfmea in the
next screen
pfmea stands for process failure mode
and effects analysis and dfmea stands
for design failure mode and effects
analysis
pfmea is used on a new or existing
process to uncover potential failures it
is done in the quality planning phase to
act as an aid during production a
process FMEA can involve fabrication
assembly transactions or services
dfmea is used in the design of a new
product service or process to uncover
potential failures the purpose is to
find out how failure modes affect the
system and to reduce the effect of
failure on the system this is done
before the product is sent to
manufacturing all design deficiencies
are sorted out at the end of this
process in the following screen we will
understand FMEA risk priority number
FMEA risk priority number or rpn is a
measure used to quantify or assess risk
associated with a design or process
assessing risk helps identify critical
failure modes higher the rpn higher the
priority the product or process receives
rpn is a product of three numbers
severity of a failure occurrence of a
failure and the detectability of a
failure
all these numbers are given a value on a
scale of 1 to 10. the minimum value of
rpn is one and the maximum value is one
thousand
a failure mode with a high occurrence
rating means the failure mode occurs
very frequently a mode with a high
severity rating means that the mode is
really critical to ensure safety of
operations
a mode with a high detection rating
means that the current controls are not
sufficient
in the next screen we will look at the
FMEA table
the FMEA table helps plan Improvement
initiatives by underlining why and how
failure modes occur and helps
organizations plan for their prevention
typically FMEA is applied on the output
of root cause analysis and is a better
tool for Focus or prioritization as
compared to multi-voting one important
aspect of FMEA is that it does not need
data
experts in a particular area can form
the FMEA table without having to look at
data from any source in functions such
as human resources the FMEA table is
very useful as there might not be much
data available to the problem-solving
team
the sample FMEA table is given on the
screen please go through the contents
for better understanding
in the following screen we will discuss
severity of risk priority number and
scale criteria
let us first discuss severity
severity refers to the seriousness of
the effect of the failure mode or how
critical the failure mode is to the
customer or the process the severity of
a failure mode is rated on a scale of 1
to 10 using a severity table
different Industries follow different
structures for the severity table
a high severity rating indicates a mode
is critical to operational safety
for example a team working on FMEA of a
radioactive plant May insert fatal as
the effect with rating 10.
another example is the severity table
for a sports team the team manager wants
to rate the severity of failure of the
team in an upcoming game
she might rate it at nine given that the
team would lose a big sponsorship should
they face defeat which could in turn be
hazardous to the team's future
shown here is a generalized table of
severity
the severity rating can never be changed
for example if a mode has a rating of 9
before Improvement it will continue to
have a rating of 9 after Improvement 2.
let us look at occurrence of RPM and
scale criteria
occurrence is the probability that a
specific cause will result in the
particular failure mode
as with severity occurrences rated on a
scale of 1 to 10 based on a table
like the severity table higher the
occurrence of a failure higher is its
rating again this table might vary
depending on the industry and scenario
sometimes the project team can use data
here if available based on past data the
probability of occurrence of a failure
can easily be rated shown here is a
generalized table let us next look at
detection of rpn and scale criteria
detection is the probability that a
particular failure will be detected
the table shown here is again a
generalized one the rating here is a bit
different from severity or occurrence
higher the detectability of a failure
lower is its rating this is because if
the failure can easily be detected then
everyone would know of it and therefore
there would be less or no damage green
in this example A Bank wants to
recognize and prioritize the risks
involved in the process of withdrawing
cash from an ATM
it can be observed from the table that
not having a control in place for
network issues has the highest RPM
this is due to the detectability for a
network issue being very low the next
set of information in the table shows
the action taken by the bank's
management to address the failure modes
following the implementation the new rpn
is calculated retaining the security
level at nine
this is because the actions were not
directed at reducing the severity but at
the causes of failure
it can be seen that the new rpn is much
lower and the risk for both causes has
been mitigated
this lesson will cover the details of
the Define phase
Six Sigma can be applied to everything
around it can be applied across almost
70 different sectors however it cannot
be applied to all problems the first
step is to check if the project
qualifies to be a Six Sigma project the
questions that need to be asked are as
follows
is there an existing process
to implement the DMACC methodology of
problem solving a process needs to exist
the process should be in operation for
the development of the product or
service
is there a problem in the process
ideally the process should not have any
problem
if there is a problem in the process
performance the process needs to be
improved
is the problem measurable
the problem has to be measurable in
order to assess the root cause and the
impact of the problem on the process
does the problem impact customer
satisfaction
if the problem affects customer
satisfaction an action needs to be taken
immediately else the customer may start
finding alternate products or switch to
competitors products
does working on the problem impact
profits of the company
it is very essential to assess the
impact of the project on the profits of
the company if the project affects the
profits of the company adversely then
such a project is not feasible
is the root cause of the problem unknown
if the root cause of the problem is
visible then a Six Sigma project is not
required other problem-solving
techniques can be used in this case
is the solution unknown
if the solution to the problem is
already known then there is no need for
any project the company can directly
implement the solution
the Define phase of DMACC will be
introduced in the next screen
the Six Sigma project process is known
as a DMACC process
Define is the first phase in the Six
Sigma project process
in the Define phase the problem is
defined and the Six Sigma team is formed
the objectives of the defined phase are
as follows
clearly Define the problem statement
through customer analysis understand
customer requirements and ensure that
the Six Sigma project goals are aligned
to these requirements
Define the objectives of the Six Sigma
project
plan the project in terms of time budget
and resource requirements
Define the team structure for the
project and establish roles and
responsibilities
in the next screen let us learn about
benchmarking
benchmarking is the process of comparing
an organization's business processes
practices and performance metrics with
that of Industry leaders
there are various types of benchmarking
let us briefly look at each type
process benchmarking entails comparing
specific processes to a leading company
or an industry standard this is useful
to obtain a simplified view of business
operations and enables a focused review
of major business functions
process benchmarking includes
comparisons of production processes data
collection processes performance
indicators and productivity and
efficiency reviews
Financial benchmarking is performed to
assess overall competitiveness and
productivity
it is done by running a detailed
financial analysis and analyzing the
result
performance benchmarking involves
comparison of products and services with
those of competitors with the intention
of evaluating the organization's
competitiveness
product benchmarking involves designing
new products or services or upgrading
existing products or services
this can involve reverse engineering a
competitor's products to study the
strengths and weaknesses and modeling
the new product on these findings
strategic benchmarking refers to
studying strategies and problem-solving
approaches in other Industries
functional benchmarking is the focused
analysis of a single function with the
aim of improving it
complex functions may need to be divided
into processes before benchmarking is
done
competitive benchmarking includes
standardizing organizational strategies
process products services and procedures
against the competitors in the same
industry
collaborative benchmarking is a type of
benchmarking where the standardization
of various business parameters is
carried out by a group of companies and
the information is shared
if the subsidiary units of a company or
its various branches carry out the
benchmarking it is called collaborative
benchmarking
let us take a look at Best Practices for
benchmarking in the next screen
best practice is a method that ensures
continuous Improvement leading to
exceptional performance
it is also a method to sustain and
develop the process continuously
some of the best practices in
benchmarking are as follows
increase the objectives or scope of
benchmarking set the standards and path
to be followed at the initial stage
reduce unnecessary effort and comply
with the scope
recognize the best in the industry to
set a benchmark
share the information derived from
benchmarking
in the next screen we will discuss
project selection
let us understand process business
process and business system in this
screen
a process is a series of steps designed
to produce a product or service to meet
the requirement of a customer
a process mainly consists of three
elements input process and output
a business process is a systematic
organization of objects such as people
machinery and materials into work
activities designed to produce a
required product or service
as shown on the screen a process is a
subset of a business process
a business process is in turn a part of
a business system
a business system is a value-added chain
of various business processes such as
sales or Finance
for example payroll calculation is a
process in the HR business process of an
I.T company which is a business system
in the next screen we will look at the
process elements
let us discuss the challenges to
business process Improvement in this
screen
the Improvement to a business process of
an organization faces challenges due to
the traditional business system
structure because it is generally
grouped around the functional aspect
the main problem in a functionally
grouped organization is the movement or
flow of a product or service a product
or service has to go through various
functions and their functional elements
to reach the customer or end user
the other problem is management of the
flow of products or Services across
various functional elements
this is difficult as usually there is no
one in charge
these business process Improvement
problems can be solved using the project
management approach to produce the
product or service
in the next screen we will learn about
process owners and different
stakeholders of a project
the representation of where the process
owner and stakeholders are placed in the
organizational hierarchy is on the
screen the process owner is a person at
a senior level in the hierarchy
he is the one who takes responsibility
for the performance and execution of a
process and also has the authority and
the ability to make necessary changes
on the other hand a stakeholder is a
person group or organization which is
affected or can affect an organization's
actions
businesses have many stakeholders like
stockholders customers suppliers company
management employees of an organization
and their families the society Etc
let us discuss the effects of process
failure on various stakeholders in the
next screen
while it is an absolute business
necessity to keep one stakeholder
satisfied at all times failure to meet
one or more process objectives may
result in negative effects on them
in such situations for the stockholders
the perceived value for the company gets
reduced customers May seek other
competitors for their deals while
imposing penalties and finding recourse
in legal action against the company
suppliers may be on the losing front
with delayed payments or not being paid
at all
company management may require cost cut
down employees will receive diminishing
wages the community and Society will be
affected due to pollution created by the
organization
in the next screen we will understand
the relationship between business and
the stakeholder
in the diagram shown on the screen each
stakeholder is both a supplier as well
as a customer forming many closed-loop
processes that must be managed
controlled balanced and optimized for
the business to thrive
communication is the key in such
situations and is facilitated through
internal company processes
the next screen covers the importance
and relevance of stakeholder analysis
stakeholder analysis is an important
task to be completed before doing a Six
Sigma project
a business has many stakeholders and any
change to a business process affects
some or all of them when a process does
not meet its objectives it results in
the stakeholders being negatively
affected which in turn affects the
organization's performance
the Six Sigma team must factor in the
reasons why a stakeholder May oppose the
change effort
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will discuss voice of
the customer
let us start with how to identify the
customer in the following screen
customers are the most important part of
any business
a customer is someone who decides to
purchase pays consumes and gets affected
by a particular product or service
it is critical to identify and
understand the customer requirements the
products or Services can be designed
according to these requirements
consequently the company is able to
provide products or Services the
customers aren't willing to purchase
there are two types of customers
internal and external customers
in the next screen we will learn about
internal customers
an internal customer can be defined as
anyone within the business system who is
affected by the product or the service
while it is being developed most often
internal customers are the employees of
the company
for example let us assume that there is
a series of processes in a particular
business system
in such a scenario the second process is
the internal customer for the first
process
the third process is an internal
customer for the second process and so
on
the basic needs of an internal customer
are to be provided proper tools and
necessary equipment imparted proper
training and given Specific Instructions
to carry out their responsibilities
however the needs are not limited to
these alone
other needs include the provision
accompany newsletters projects
storyboards to display the letters Etc
team meetings to share business news and
announcements staff meeting to share
information and quality awards from
suppliers
an internal customer is important first
of all the activities of an internal
customer directly affect the final or
ultimate customer
secondly the activities of an internal
customer affect the next process in the
system finally an internal customer also
affects the quality of the product
developed or service provided
when the needs of the internal customers
in most cases employees are met they are
more likely to have higher perceptions
of quality and also contribute to
Greater productivity
the satisfaction levels of the internal
customers can be improved in various
ways these include a higher amount of
internal communication through company
newsletters and team meetings
recognitions for work quality Awards Etc
constant training on how to be ahead and
well equipped in a competitive
environment is very essential too
in the next screen we will learn about
external customers
this screen focuses on the positive
effects of a project on the customers
the most important aspect of any process
Improvement project is the customers
internal customers are the ones who
drive the project hence the effect of
the project on internal customers is a
critical factor that needs to be
considered
the positive impact of a project on the
internal customers is as follows
the project is driven by highly
motivated individuals or internal
customers who are aware of the project
objectives and scope
individuals belonging to a credible
project understand the project
deliverables and display high levels of
job satisfaction
these individuals go the extra mile to
take up tasks beyond their job
description
such individuals make a highly motivated
team focused on delivering their
responsibilities in order to meet the
customer requirements
working together in a positive
environment also improves team spirit
and bonding
the positive impact of a project on the
external customers is as follows
process Improvement projects analyze the
problems and come up with an effective
solution consequently ensuring a better
product
a successful process Improvement project
assists the organization in effectively
meeting customer expectations or
requirements
there is visible Improvement in customer
service
good quality product and service ensures
High customer satisfaction
let us learn about different methods of
customer data collection in the
following screen
once you begin to identify the customer
types you need to look forward to
collecting customer data
collecting data from customers is very
essential as it helps consider the
levels at which these customers affect
the business
Begin by collecting feedback from both
internal as well as external customers
customer feedback helps fill the gaps
and improve the various business
processes in the organization
it helps Define a good quality product
as perceived by the customer and
identify qualities that make the
competitors products or service better
it also helps identify factors which
provide a Competitive Edge to the
product or service on offer
there are various methods to collect
feedback from the customers many of you
might be involved in a similar activity
at some point or the other
popular and common methods are surveys
conducted through questionnaires focus
groups individual interviews with the
customers
customer complaints received via call
centers emails and feedback forms are
also quite prevalent
feedback received in this form are from
dissatisfied customers
in the next screen we will learn about
questionnaires
let us discuss the advantages and
disadvantages of questionnaires in this
screen
the advantages of a questionnaire are
that it costs less the phone response
rate is high anywhere from around 70 to
90 percent and it produces faster
results
also analysis of mail questionnaires
requires few trained resources
questionnaire is a method used to gather
data however there are a few
disadvantages associated with it
there may be incomplete results and
unanswered questions leading to a lack
of clarity
the response rate of mail surveys is
about 20 to 30 percent only
at times phone surveys can produce
undesirable results as the interviewer
can influence the person being
interviewed
we will differentiate between telephone
survey and web survey in the next screen
there are different methods to collect
data for a survey the methods need to be
based on the requirements and needs of
the organization the popular methods of
survey are the telephone survey and web
survey
both have their own drawbacks and
benefits which are given on the screen
the organization needs to choose a
method of collecting data according to
the situation
it is recommended to go through the
content for a better understanding
in the next screen we will learn about
focus groups
let us now discuss the advantages and
disadvantages of using a focus group for
data collection the interaction in a
focus group generates information
provides in-depth responses and can
address more complex questions or
qualitative data it is an excellent
platform to get critical to Quality or
ctq definitions as well
on the other hand the disadvantages of
focus groups are that the learning only
applies to those within the group and it
is not possible to generalize
The information collected is more
qualitative than quantitative which is
another drawback additionally they can
also generate a lot of information from
anecdotes and incidents experienced by
the individuals in the group
in the next screen we will discuss the
interview technique
this screen discusses advantages and
disadvantages of using the interview
technique for data collection
interviews have a capability to handle
complex questions and a large amount of
information they also allow us to use
visual aids in the process
it is a better method to be employed
when people do not respond willingly and
or accurately by phone or email however
there are some shortcomings as well
interviews are time consuming and the
resources or interviewer needs to be
trained and experienced to carry out the
task let us discuss the importance and
urgency of these inputs in the next
screen
the table shows the importance and
urgency of different kinds of input
to understand the kind of input to be
chosen different kinds of methods for
collecting data are identified
telephone survey web survey and
interview are the data collection
methods identified
to select the best methods the criteria
or the factors which are important to
the organization are listed
the criteria are the factors based on
which an organization is going to make
decisions the list of factors is then
given weightage based on the importance
of each factor in decision making as
seen cost is the most important
Criterion for which the weightage is
given 20. response rate of the customer
is next important factor and the list
follows
visualizing feature and compiling and
analyzing data are the factors which
have the lowest impact on the decision
of selecting the methods for data
collection
each of the data collecting methods is
rated between 1 and 10 based on its
impact on the listed factors with 10
being highly favorable to the
organization and one being least
favorable
after rating all the methods with the
factors listed the sum or total is
calculated the calculation of the total
involves multiplying each method's
rating with the factor weightage and
adding all the multiplied values of the
column that is for telephone survey the
rating is Multiplied with factors rating
eight multiplied by 12 plus 8 multiplied
by 6 plus 3 multiplied by Twenty plus
five multiplied by five plus three
multiplied by five plus seven multiplied
by fifteen plus one multiplied by ten
plus seven multiplied by three plus zero
multiplied by two plus three multiplied
by two plus one multiplied by ten plus
seven multiplied by five plus eight
multiplied by five and the total of this
is four hundred seventy one
in a similar way calculate the total
value for the remaining two methods the
total of other two methods are 744 and
522 respectively looking at the overall
total of the methods 744 is the highest
hence web survey is the best method for
the organization to use for data
collection
let us look at the pros and cons of
customer complaints data in the next
screen
there are pros and cons in gathering
information from customer complaints
advantages include availability of
specific feedback directly from the
customer and E is in responding
appropriately to every customer on the
contrary feedback in this method does
not provide an adequate sample size and
may lead to process changes based on one
or two inputs from the customer
the next screen will discuss the
difference between product complaint and
expedited service request
product complaints and expedited service
requests can act as inputs to the
company for improving their process
these details address the needs of the
customer in an indirect way
a product complaint means that the
customer is not happy with the product
that he has purchased from the company
an expedited service request means a
service request is being rushed if the
customer requires the items immediately
then an expedited service request is
raised from the customer and the
organization tries to fulfill it to
please the customer
product complaint implies that a product
is not meeting customer specification
hence it has to be improved expedited
service request implies that service
timeliness are not meeting customer
requirements hence service has to be
improved
a product complaint also implies that
the customer needs for product are not
completely identified whereas expedited
service request implies that the
customer timings need to be recalculated
let us discuss the importance and
urgency of these inputs in the next
screen
the table shows the importance and
urgency of different kinds of input
to select the best methods the criteria
or the factors which are important to
the organization are listed the criteria
are the factors based on which
organization is going to make decisions
these factors are then given weightage
based on the importance of each factor
in decision making
as seen cost involved and identification
of customer need are the most important
criteria for which the weightage given
is 15 and the list follows time
consumption and compiling and analyzing
data are the factors which have the
least impact on the decision of
selecting the methods for data
collection
each method is rated between 1 and 10
based on its impact of the listed
factors with 10 being highly favorable
to the organization and one being least
favorable to the organization
after reading all the methods with the
factors listed the sum or total is
calculated
calculation of the total is derived by
multiplying each method's rating with
the factor weightage and adding all the
multiplied values
that is for a product complaint the
rating is Multiplied with the factors
rating eight multiplied by fifteen plus
four multiplied by fifteen plus three
multiplied by two plus one multiplied by
ten plus one multiplied by ten plus one
multiplied by ten plus one multiplied by
eight plus one multiplied by ten plus
four multiplied by two plus one
multiplied by eight plus one multiplied
by ten and the total of this is two
hundred sixty
in the similar way calculate the total
value for expedited service request
the total of expedited service request
is 817 and hence it is effective to the
organization
let us discuss the key elements of data
collection tools in the next screen
data collection tools will be selected
based on the type of data to be
collected the key elements that make
these tools effective are as follows
data is collected directly from the
primary source or customer hence there
is no scope for miscommunication or loss
of information
data is collected exclusively for the
stated purpose hence data is highly
reliable the data is captured is after
understanding the organizational purpose
this makes the data exclusively relevant
and serves the purpose of the
organization
data is collected instantaneously when
there is a requirement this ensures that
the data is up to date hence the data is
valid the tools accurately Define
customer requirements the customer
requirements could be current needs or
Improvement to the product or service
that they are currently using the tools
help to get enough information about
customer requirement through which the
process for improving or creating the
product or service that the customer
requires can be developed
in the next screen we will discuss how
the collected data can be reviewed
collated data must be reviewed to
eliminate vagueness ambiguity and any
unintended bias
neutral worldwide buys laptops for its
employees from a company that is into
manufacture and sales of laptops the
company also provides servicing and
repairs for their products to the
customers
to understand the level of customer
satisfaction in neutral worldwide and to
improve its process the laptop company
is conducting a survey the questionnaire
which was prepared initially
questionnaire before review had
questions that led to ambiguity
vagueness and unintended bias
let us look at each item on the survey
to understand the level of usage of the
laptop and to know their customer better
the survey is raising a question related
to the occupation of the customer
it gives the option of student or
professional
but with this low amount of information
the company is neither able to gather
the information nor will the given
option cover the entire possible
occupation in the market including an
option of other please specify would
help the customer to choose and provide
the information if he does not belong to
one of the two given groups hence the
same is added in the review so that the
customer will not be in any ambiguity
while filling the questionnaire
the question whether the sales executive
was supportive with an option of yes or
no is a question which leads again to
ambiguity and unintended bias the
customer might be partially happy or
partially not happy but the choice does
not let them inform their exact feeling
if the customer selects no as the option
then the company does not get enough
information to understand where their
sales executive went wrong
hence in the reviewed questionnaire the
customer is asked to rate the qualities
of their sales executive which will
provide better data to the company in
order to improve the process
next we will discuss a technique named
voice of customer
the voice of customer is a technique to
organize analyze and profile the
customer's requirements voice of the
customer is an expression for listening
to the external customer
the table shows the customer
requirements while purchasing an air
conditioner in all cases the customer is
purchasing for his or her domestic usage
each customer is further categorized
according to his needs and requirements
when the customer says that he needs a
silent air conditioner he needs sound
sleep at night in the bedroom
this is primarily to remain fresh the
next morning and to get rid of the noisy
ceiling fan being used currently in case
the customer says that he needs an
efficient AC he needs a machine which
provides good cooling at night in the
bedroom this is mainly because it gets
extremely hot in summer also he
currently uses a ceiling fan which is
not so effective in Summers on the other
hand when the customer wants to buy an
AC which is not too costly he has
limited cash for the purchase he wants
to purchase a low-cost AC
let us discuss the importance of
translating customer requirements in the
next screen
customer requirement is the data
collected from customers that gives
information about what they need or want
from the process customer requirements
are often high level vague and
non-specific some customers may give you
a set of specific requirements to the
business but broadly customers
requirements are a reflection of their
experience
customer requirements when translated
into critical process requirements that
are specific and measurable are called
critical to Quality ctq factors a fully
developed ctq has four major elements
output characteristic y metric Target
and specification or tolerance limits we
will discuss the meaning of ctq in the
next screen
let us understand what Quality Function
deployment is in this screen
qfd is a process to ensure that the
customers wants and needs are heard and
translated into technical
characteristics
it is also known as the voice of the
customer or House of quality
qfd is a process to understand the
customer's needs and translate them into
a set of design and Manufacturing
requirements while motivating businesses
to focus on their customers it also
helps companies to design and build more
competitive products in less time and
lesser costs
qfd helps in prioritizing customer
requirements recognizing strengths and
weaknesses of an organization and
recognizing areas that need to be worked
on and areas that need immediate focus
of efforts qfd is carried out by asking
relevant questions to the customers and
tabulating them to bring out a set of
parameters critical to the product
design let us discuss phases of qfd in
the next screen
Quality Function deployment involves
four phases phase one product planning
in this phase the qfd team translates
the customer requirements into product
technical requirements
Phase 2 product design in this phase the
qfd team translates the identified
technical requirements into key part
characteristics or systems
phase 3 process planning
in this phase the qfd team identifies
the key process operations necessary to
achieve the identified key part
characteristics
phase four production planning or
process control
in this phase the qfd team establishes
process control plans maintenance plans
and training plans to control operations
next we will understand the structure of
qfd
let us see what happens after completing
the hoq Matrix
completing one hoq Matrix is not the end
of the qfd process
the output of the first hoq Matrix can
be the first stage of the second qfd
phase as shown in the image the
translation process is continued using
linked hoq type matrices until the
production planning targets are
developed
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will discuss the basics
of project management let us start with
a discussion on problem statement
every Six Sigma project targets a
problem that needs to be resolved the
first step of project initiation is
defining the problem statement a problem
statement needs to describe the problem
in a clear and concise manner
a problem statement needs to identify
and specify The observed Gap in
performance it should indicate the
current performance state of a process
and the required performance State
completely derived from customer
requirements a problem statement should
be quantifiable this means it should
have specified metrics including the
respective units please note that the
problem statement cannot contain
Solutions or causes for the problem in
the next screen we will discuss the is
or is not template
the is or is not technique was first
popularized by Kepner triggo
Incorporated in the 1970s it is a
powerful tool that helps Define the
problem and gather required information
an example of a problem statement of
paper cup leaks is given on the screen
the Six Sigma team has to answer what is
the problem what isn't the problem where
is it where isn't it when is it when
isn't it a problem to what extent is it
a problem and to what extent isn't it a
problem
the information is then used to fill the
question areas in the is and is not
issue template in the analysis phase if
a cause cannot describe the is and the
is not data then it's not likely the
main cause in the next screen we will
list the criteria for the project
objectives
the project objectives must meet the
smarts criteria smarts is an acronym of
the characteristics desired in Project
objectives specific measurable
attainable relevant time-based and
stretch
the project deliverables should be
specific example hospitals maintain
records of all patients often a few
forms are rejected or missed due to
errors in recording the ID numbers
in this case setting the objective as
reduced form rejection is very vague
instead reduce patient ID errors in
recording lab results is specific and
effectively targets solving the problem
the project objectives should be
quantifiable example setting the
objective as fewer form rejections is
very vague instead reduce patient ID
Errors By 30 percent sets a specific
goal the project objectives should be
achievable and practical the project
objectives should be relevant to the
problem the project objectives must
specify a time frame within which they
should be delivered the project
objectives must not be easily achievable
example most problems and errors can be
reduced by creating awareness hence the
objective must stretch beyond the easily
attainable state
in the next screen we will understand
project documentation
project documentation refers to creating
documents to provide details about the
project
such documents are used to gain a better
understanding of the project prevent and
resolve conflict among stakeholders and
Share Plans and status for the project
documentation of a project is critical
throughout the project some of the
benefits achieved through project
documentation are mentioned below
documentation serves as written proof
for execution of the project it helps
teams achieve a common understanding of
the requirements and the status of the
project
it removes personal bias as there is a
documented history of discussions and
decisions made for the project
depending on the nature of the project
each project produces a number of
different documents some of these
documents are the project Charter
project plan and its subsidiary plans
other examples of project documentation
include project status reports including
key Milestones report risk items and
pending action items the frequency of
these reports is determined by the need
and complexity of the project these
reports are sent to All stakeholders to
keep them abreast of the status of the
project another example of project
documentation is the final project
report this report is prepared at the
end of the project and includes a
summary of the complete project
project storyboard inputs generated from
statistical tools outputs from
spreadsheets checklists and other
miscellaneous documents are also
classified as project documents in the
next screen we will understand project
Charter
we will list the project Charter
sections in this screen the major
sections of a project Charter are
project name and description business
requirements name of the project manager
project purpose or justification
including Roi stakeholder and
stakeholder requirements broad timelines
major deliverables constraints and
assumptions and the budget summary of
the charter in the next screen we will
understand the project plan
a project plan is the final approved
document which is used to manage and
control the various processes within the
project and ensure its seamless
execution
the project manager uses the project
Charter as an input to create a detailed
project plan
a project plan comprises various
sections prominent among them being the
project management approach the scope
statement the work breakdown structure
the cost estimates scheduling defining
performance baselines marking major
Milestones to be achieved and the key
members and required staff Personnel for
the project
it also includes the various open and
pending decisions related to the project
and the key risks involved additionally
it also contains references to other
subsidiary plans for managing risk scope
schedule Etc
in the next screen we will learn about
project scope
we will look at different techniques
used for interpreting the project scope
in this screen project scope can be
interpreted from the problem statement
and project Charter using various tools
like the Pareto chart and the cypok map
the principle behind the burrito chart
or the 80 20 Principle as we know it is
a vital few trivial many
the burrito chart helps the teams to
trim the scope of the project by
identifying the causes which have a
major impact on the outcome of the
project
the cypok map is a high level process
map which helps all team members in
understanding the process functions in
terms of addressing questions like who
are the suppliers what are the inputs
they provide what are the outputs that
can be obtained and who are the
customers
as discussed earlier cypok stands for
suppliers inputs process outputs and
customers
in the subsequent screen we will learn
about process Maps
cypok is a macro level map that provides
an overview of the business process
where a process map is a micro level
flowchart that provides an in-depth
detail of a process
the process map covers details at all
levels and provides a walk through the
current process experience
the cypok map is used as a basis while
drawing a process map
a level 1 process map provides in-depth
information but the final process map
drills further into detail in the
following screen we will understand the
project metrics
let us discuss consequential metrics in
this screen
consequential metrics measure any
negative consequences these can be
business metrics process metrics or both
they measure the negative effects of
improving the primary or key metrics
they are used to measure the indemnity
triggered by any damage in the project
the inconsistent use of consequential
metrics can lead to loss of opportunity
and rework after a project ends
consequential metrics help to understand
the cause and effect relationship
between the primary and the secondary
metrics and the impact it has on the
organization
let us take a look at an example for
consequential metrics in the next screen
we will discuss the best practices in
this screen the following are some of
the best practices of consequential
metrics
setting consequential metrics during the
measure phase and monitoring these
metrics after finalizing the project
will help to analyze whether the link
between previous primary and secondary
metrics has been established
also linking consequential metrics with
primary metrics and finally linking them
with secondary metrics provides Clarity
on the impact of these metrics
assessing and evaluating the cause and
effect relationship between these
metrics is helpful to the organization
as a whole in the next screen we will
list some project planning tools
the project manager uses various tools
to plan and control a project
one of the tools which he uses is the
burrito chart other prominent tools
include the network diagram the critical
path method also called CPM the program
evaluation and review technique which is
also known as pert Gantt charts and the
work breakdown structure also known as
WBS in the next screen we will discuss
burrito chart
Pareto chart is a histogram ordered by
the frequency of occurrence of events it
is also known as the 80 20 rule or vital
view trivial many
it helps project teams to focus on the
issues which cause the highest number of
defects or complaints
to explain further the given chart plots
all the causes for defects in a product
or service the values are represented in
descending order by bars and the
cumulative total is represented by the
line
burrito chart emphasizes that 80 percent
of the effects come from 20 percent of
the causes
thus a burrito chart Narrows the scope
of the project or problem solving by
identifying the major causes affecting
quality
burrito charts are useful only when
required data is available
if data is not available then other
tools such as brainstorming and
multi-voting should be used to find the
root cause of any problem
in the following screen we will continue
to discuss burrito chart with an example
a hotel receives plenty of complaints
from its customers and the hotel manager
wishes to identify the key areas of
complaints complaints were received in
the following areas cleaning check-in
pool timings minibar room service and
miscellaneous
cleaning and check-in can be noted as
areas of concern with 35 and 19
complaints respectively
percentages calculated for each cause of
complaint and the cumulative is derived
burrito chart is plotted using this data
in the next screen we will discuss
Network diagrams
Network diagrams are one of the tools
used by the project manager for project
planning they are also sometimes
referred to as Arrow diagrams because
they use arrows to connect activities
and represent precedence and
interdependencies between activities of
a project
there are some assumptions that need to
be made while forming the network
diagram
the first assumption is that before a
new activity begins all pending
activities have been completed
the second assumption is that all arrows
indicate logical precedence
this means that the direction of the
arrow represents the sequence that
activities need to follow the last
assumption is that a network diagram
must start from a single event and end
with a single event there cannot be
multiple start and end points to the
network diagram in the next screen let
us discuss some terms related to network
diagram
for the network diagram to calculate the
total duration of the project the
project manager needs to Define four
dates for each task the first two dates
relate to the date by when the task can
be started the first date is early start
this is the earliest date by when the
task can start
the second date is late start this is
the last date by when the task should
start
the second two dates relate to the dates
when the task should be complete
early finish is the earliest date by
when the task can be completed
late finish is the last date by when the
task should be completed
the duration of the task is calculated
as the difference between the early
start and early finish of the task
the difference between the early start
and late start of the task is called the
slack time available for the task
slack can also be calculated as the
difference between the early finish and
late finish dates of the task
slack time or float time for a task is
the amount of time the task can be
delayed before it causes a delay in the
overall project timeline
in the next screen we will discuss
critical path method
critical path method also known as CPM
is an important tool used by project
managers to monitor the progress of the
project and to ensure that the project
is on schedule
the critical path for a project is the
longest sequence of tasks on the network
diagram
the critical path in the given Network
diagram is highlighted in Orange
critical path is characterized by zero
slack for all tasks on the sequence
this means that the smallest delay in
any other tasks on the critical path
will cause a delay in the overall
timeline of the project this makes it
very important for the project manager
to closely monitor the tasks on the
critical path and ensure that the tasks
go smoothly if needed the project
manager can divert resources from other
tasks that are not on the critical path
to task on the critical path to ensure
that the project is not delayed
when a project manager removes resources
from such tasks he needs to ensure that
the task does not become a critical path
task because of the reduced number of
resources
during the execution of the project the
critical path can easily shift because
of multiple factors and hence needs to
be constantly monitored by the project
manager a complex project can also have
multiple critical paths in the next
screen we will discuss project
evaluation and review technique
we will understand the concept of risk
in this screen
risk is an uncertain event or a
consequence probable of occurring during
a project
the main objectives of any project are
time cost quality and scope
risk affects at least one of the four
project objectives
it is important to understand that risk
can be both positive as well as negative
a positive risk enhances the success of
the project whereas a negative risk is a
threat to a Project's success some of
the terms used in Risk analysis and
management are risk probability issue
and risk consequences the likelihood
that a risk will occur is called risk
probability
to assess any risk is to assess the
probability and impact of the risk
issue is the occurrence of a risk risk
consequences are the effects on Project
objectives if there is an occurrence of
a risk or issue
in the subsequent screen we will
understand the process of risk analysis
and management
we will list and understand some of the
elements of risk analysis in this screen
qualitative method
qualitative methods like interview
checklists and brainstorming are used to
identify potential risks
quantitative method quantitative methods
are databased and a computer is required
to calculate and analyze
these methods are used to evaluate the
cost time and probabilistic combination
of individual uncertainties
feasibility
feasibility is the study of the project
risk this is usually carried out in the
beginning of the project when the
project is most flexible and risks can
be reduced at a relatively low cost
it helps in deciding different
implementing options for the projects
potential impact once the potential
risks are identified the impact of these
on the project is determined
using this data possible solutions for
the risks are identified
rpn
rpn of a failure is the product of its
probability of occurrence severity and
detectability
a failure is prioritized based on its
rpn value
a high rpn indicates high risk rpn
assists to prioritize risks
avoiding risk
when potential risks are identified
their impact in terms of cost time
resources and objective perspective is
calculated
if the impact is huge then avoiding the
risk is the best option
mitigating risk mitigating is the second
option when dealing with risks the loss
that arises from mitigating a risk is
much less than the loss that arises from
the temporary avoiding of risk
accepting the risk if a risk cannot be
avoided or mitigated then it has to be
accepted the risk will be accepted if it
doesn't greatly impact the cost time and
product objective
in the following screen we will discuss
benefits of risk analysis
benefits of risk analysis are as follows
once the risk has been identified it can
be either mitigated transferred or
accepted
when risk is identified in a task slack
time is provided as a buffer identifying
risks also helps in setting up an actual
timeline for a project
slack time for an activity in a project
could be the result of a risk identified
proactively
identifying risks helps in setting
realistic expectations from the project
by communicating the risk probability
and consequence to stakeholders
risk analysis also helps to identify and
plan contingency activities if the risk
becomes an issue the project team is
then well prepared to work on the issue
thereby reducing the impact of the risk
in the following screen we will take a
look at the risk assessment Matrix
the potential risks of a project are
assessed using the risk assessment
Matrix it covers potential risk areas
like project scope team Personnel
material facility and equipment and
communication
each of these areas is assessed in terms
of risk of loss of money productivity
resources and customer confidence
in the subsequent screen we will discuss
project closure
by definition a project has a beginning
and an end but without a formal closure
process project teams can fail to
recognize the end and then the project
can drag on sometimes at Great expense
every project requires closure for
larger complex projects it's a good idea
to close each major project phase for
example design code and test
individually
project closure ensures that outcomes
match the stated goals of the project
customers and stakeholders are happy
with the results
critical knowledge is captured
the team feels a sense of completion and
project resources are released for new
projects
in the next screen we will list the
goals of a project closure report
the project closure report is created to
accomplish the following goals
review and validate the success of the
project confirm outstanding issues
limitations and recommendations
outline tasks and activities
accomplished to complete the activity
highlight the best practices for future
projects
provide the project report or summary
provide a project background overview
summarize the planned activities of a
project
evaluate project performance
provide a synopsis of the process
generate discussions and recommendations
generate project closure recommendations
in the following screen we will list and
understand project closure activities
during project closure the project
manager needs to take care of the
following activities
finalize the project documents
much of a Project's documentation is
created during the life of the project
document collection and update
procedures are well established during
the project lifeline
capture the project knowledge
project documents are helpful for future
projects in troubleshooting the product
or in a future audit
set up a project Library
ideally the project library is set up at
the beginning of the project and team
members add documents as they produce
them
document the project learnings
project learnings can be captured
through team meetings meetings with
stakeholders and sponsor and through
feedbacks from consultants and vendors
provide knowledge transfer
the project manager needs to provide a
summary of the project results to team
members either as a presentation at a
meeting or as a formal document
Consultants should not be relieved from
their position until they have
transferred all the important product
maintenance knowledge to the team
get a final sign off schedule a meeting
with the project sponsor and key
stakeholders to get their final sign off
on the project
close the project office
if the project team used a project
management office or a dedicated work
area Arrangements need to be made to
return that space for General use
recognize and reward
the project manager has the best
understanding of which of the team
members have worked the best have
transformed themselves with new skills
and who might be ready for a new level
of responsibility the project manager
needs to report to the team's superiors
what each team member has brought to the
project
celebrate
after completion of every project the
team needs and deserves a celebration a
team dinner a team outing gift
certificates or other rewards are minor
costs that generate a large return in
terms of morale and job satisfaction
make a public announcement an
announcement to the organization is a
good way to highlight the success of the
project and its benefits to the company
conclude
formal project closure ensures that the
team has met its objectives satisfied
the customer captured important
knowledge and been rewarded for their
efforts
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will discuss management
and planning tools
let us start with the discussion on
Affinity diagram in the next screen
the Affinity diagram method is employed
by an individual or team to solve
unfamiliar problems it is an effective
medium where the consensus of the group
is necessary
the given Affinity diagram is based on
an organization where the employees are
not satisfied
to begin with each member writes down
ideas and opinions on sticky notes each
note can have a single idea the points
which have surfaced during the
brainstorming session are that the
workers are unkind pay is low and it is
difficult to survive on the pay
structure working hours are too long Etc
in The Next Step all the sticky notes
are pasted on a table or wall
the sticky papers are arranged according
to categories or thought patterns
members happen to arrange their ideas
based on Affinity in case a particular
idea is good to go into more than one
category it is duplicated and added to
several categories
after the arrangement is done each
category is named with a header card
the header card captures the central
idea of all the cards in that category
and draws a boundary around them
poor compensation combines ideas like
low pay long working hours and
complaints about wages
poor work environment encompasses issues
like poor lighting uncomfortable rooms
and stuffy air
similarly poor relationships prevailed
in the workspace as the workers are
unkind and there is mutual dislike
lack of motivation is due to repetitive
work and no work related challenges
you can see in the diagram on that slide
that once all the ideas are grouped to
the respective header cards a diagram is
drawn and borders are placed around the
group of ideas thus Affinity diagram
helps in grouping ideas with the common
theme
in the next screen we will discuss the
interrelationship diagram
during problem solving the
interrelationship diagram technique
helps in identifying the relationship
between problems and ideas in complex
situations
if the problem is really complex it may
not be easy to determine the exact
relationship between ideas
the given interrelationship diagram is
the result of a team brainstorming
session which identified 10 major issues
involved in developing an organization's
quality plan
initially the problem is defined and all
the members put down their ideas on
sticky notes each note contains only one
idea
all the sticky notes are put on a table
for a random display
in The Next Step the causes or areas of
concern are identified and a
cause-effect arrangement of cards is
constructed by drawing an arrow between
the causes and effects of the cause
this is done until all the ideas on the
sticky notes are accounted for and made
a part of the interrelationship diagram
take a large sheet of paper and
replicate the cause effect Arrangement
on it
as depicted in the image a large number
of outgoing arrows indicate the root
cause
whereas a higher number of incoming
arrows indicates an outcome
there are as many as six arrows
originating from lack of quality
strategy
this leads us to understand that it is a
root cause
on the other hand there are three arrows
ending with the idea lack of tqm
commitment by managers making it an
outcome
in the next screen we will understand
the tree diagram
the tree diagram is a systematic
approach to outline all the details
needed to complete a given objective
in other words it is a method used to
identify the tasks and methods needed to
solve a problem and reach a predefined
goal it is mostly used while developing
actions to execute a solution while
analyzing processes in detail during the
evaluation of implementation issues for
several potential Solutions and also as
a communication tool to explain the
details of a process to others
the given tree diagram shows the plan of
a coffee shop trying to set standards
for the coffee it delivers
first the objective is noted on a note
card and placed on the far left side of
the board the basic goal of the coffee
shop is to provide a delightful
cappuccino experience
in The Next Step the coffee shop needs
to determine the means required to
achieve the goal and furnish three
different solutions
in other words the answers to the how or
why questions of the objectives
in this case the cappuccino needs to be
at a comfortable temperature and it
should have strong and pleasing coffee
Aroma with the right amount of sweetness
in The Next Step the three issues
mentioned in the second stage are
addressed at length
each issue is answered by maintaining
the espresso and steamed milk
temperature the cappuccino can be served
at a palatable temperature
strong flavored cappuccino can be
prepared using a good amount of finely
ground coffee beans
and a good quality sweetener used in the
right amount makes a great cappuccino
thus the tree diagram can be used to
achieve a goal or Define a process
in the following screen we will discuss
prioritization matrices
let us learn about Matrix diagram in
this screen
Matrix diagrams show the relationship
between objectives and methods results
and causes tasks and people
Etc their objective is to provide
information about the relationship
they provide importance of tasks and
Method elements of the subject
they also help determine the strength of
relationships between a grid of rows and
columns
they help in organizing a large amount
of inter-process related activities
let us discuss various types of matrices
in the next screen
let us learn about a process decision
program chart in this screen
process decision program chart or the
pdpc method is used to chart the course
of events from the beginning of a
process till the goal while emphasizing
the ability to identify the failure of
important issues on activity plans the
pdpc helps create appropriate
contingency plans to limit the number of
risks involved the pdpc is used before
implementing a plan especially when the
plan is large and complex if the plan
must be completed on schedule or if the
price of failure is quite High
the given process decision program chart
shows the process which can help in
securing a contract
the process starts when the seller
receives an order request from a
potential buyer this can lead to fixing
an appointment with the buyer confirming
the appointment date and meeting the
buyer
if a date is not fixed then buyers
should be contacted till the meeting is
confirmed without a meeting there is a
risk of losing the order
considering an optimistic scenario where
a meeting is fixed with a buyer the
seller describes the price of the
product or service if the price is
competitive the order is secured
if the price is not competitive the
seller may have to repeat the bid until
the buyer agrees and the order is secure
however the buyer may not agree to a
revised bid either in which case the
seller might lose the bid
in such a scenario the seller can
justify the pricing and pursue the buyer
to agree to the bid
it might work and the seller might
secure the order
in the next screen we will discuss the
activity Network diagram
and activity Network diagram is used to
show the time required for solving a
problem and to identify items that can
be done in parallel
it is used in scheduling and monitoring
tasks within a complex project or
process with interrelated tasks and
resources moreover it is also used when
you know the steps of the project or
process their sequence and the time
taken by each of the steps involved the
original Japanese name for this tool is
Arrow diagram
the given activity Network diagram shows
a house construction plan and identifies
the factors involved separately like the
amount of time for each operation in one
situation the relationship of work
without time for each operation and an
operation by itself
the number of days is denoted by D so
the time taken for an activity like
Foundation to scaffolding takes around
five days plus four days which is nine
days in total malign joining electrical
work and interior walls is dotted this
shows relation between them but without
any timeline
basically it means that electrical work
has to be done before interior walls but
the time is either not important or not
available
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will introduce business
results for projects let us start with
the discussion on defect per unit
we will learn about throughput yield in
this screen
throughput yield or tpy is the number of
acceptable pieces at the end of a
process divided by the number of
starting pieces excluding scrap and
rework
throughput yield is used to measure a
single process only
if the dpu is known tpy can be easily
calculated as e to the power of the
negative of dpu here e is the
mathematical constant and has a value of
2.7183 the expression can also be stated
as dpu equals the negative of natural
logarithm e of tpy
in the next screen we will discuss
rolled throughput yield
rolled throughput yield or rty is the
probability of the entire process
producing zero defects rty is the true
measure of process efficiency and is
considered across multiple processes
it is important as a metric when a
process has excessive rework
tdpu is total defects per unit and is
defined for a set of processes when the
total defects per unit is known rolled
throughput yield is calculated using the
expression e to the power of negative of
tdpu
the expression can also be written as
tdpu is equal to negative of natural
logarithm of rty
when the defectives are known roll
throughput yield can be calculated as
the product of each process's first pass
yield or fpy
first pass yield is the number of
products which pass without any rework
over the total number of units
first pass yield is calculated as total
number of quality products over total
number of units
total number of quality products is
total number of units minus total number
of defective units
in the following screen we will
understand fby and rty with an example
we will discuss process capability in
this screen
process capability or CP is defined as
the inherent variability of a
characteristic of a process or a product
in other words it might also mean how
well a process meets customer
requirement
CP is an indicator of capability of a
process and is expressed as difference
of USL and LSL divided by product of Six
Sigma
USL stands for upper specification limit
LSL is lower specification limit and
sigma is the standard deviation of a
process the difference between USL and
LSL is also called the specification
width or tolerance in the following
screen we will discuss process
capability indices
process capability indices or CPK was
developed to objectively measure the
degree to which a process meets or does
not meet customer requirements it was
developed to account for the position of
mean with respect to USL and LSL
to calculate CPK the first step is to
determine if the process mean is closer
to the LSL or the USL if the process
mean is closer to LSL
cpkl is determined
cpkl is mean minus LSL divided by
product of 3 and sigma if the process
mean is closer to USL cpku is calculated
cpku is USL minus mean divided by
product of 3 and sigma here mean is the
process average and sigma represents the
standard deviation
if the process mean is equidistant
either of the specification limit can be
chosen CPK takes up the value of cpku
and cpkl depending on whichever is the
lower value in the next screen we will
understand process capability indices
with an example
in this screen we will discuss CPK and
CP interpretations
a CP value of less than one indicates
the process is not capable
even if CP is greater than one to
ascertain if the process really is not
capable check the CPK value
a CPK value of less than one indicates
that the process is definitely not
capable but might be if CP is greater
than one and the process mean is at or
near the midpoint of the tolerance range
the CPK value will always be less than
CP especially as long as the process
mean is not at the center of the process
tolerance range
non-centering can happen when the
process has not understood the customer
expectations clearly or the process is
complete as soon as the output reaches a
specific limit
for example a shirt size of 40 has a
Target chest diameter of 40 inches but
the process consistently delivers shirts
with a mean of 41 inches as the chest
diameter
a machine stops removing material as
soon as the measured Dimension is within
specified limit
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will discuss Team
Dynamics and performance let us start
with a discussion on team stages
there are five typical stages in the
team building process each team passes
through these stages as they start and
proceed through the project
the five stages in the team building
process are as follows forming storming
norming performing and adjourning
in the next screen we will discuss the
first stage forming
the first stage in the team building
process is called the forming stage in
this stage the team comes together and
begins to formulate roles and
responsibilities the team leader is
identified and he or she starts
directing the team and assigning
responsibilities to other team members
most team members at this stage are
generally enthusiastic and motivated by
a desire to be accepted within the team
the leader employs a directive style of
management which includes delegating
responsibility within the team providing
a structure to the team and determining
processes needed for the smooth
functioning of the team
toward the end of this phase the team
should achieve a commitment to the
project and an acceptance of a common
purpose
in the next screen we will discuss the
second stage storming
the second phase in the team building
process is called the storming stage as
suggested by the name itself in this
stage conflicts start to arise within
the team team members often struggle
over responsibilities and control within
the project
it is the responsibility of the team
leader to coach and conciliate the team
the leader employs a coaching style of
management which is reflected through
facilitating change managing conflict
and mediating understanding between
different parties
towards the end of this phase team
members need to learn to voice
disagreement openly and constructively
while staying focused on common
objectives and areas of agreement
in the next screen we will discuss the
third stage norming
the third stage in the team building
process is called the norming stage
in this stage people get along and the
team develops a unified commitment
toward the project goal the team leader
promotes the team and participates in
the team activities team members look to
the leader to clarify their
understanding as some leadership roles
begin to shift within the lower rungs of
the group
the later employees a participatory
style of management through facilitating
change working to build consensus and
overseeing quality control
toward the end of this phase team
members need to accept individual
responsibilities and work out agreements
about team procedures
in the next screen we will discuss the
fourth stage performing
the next stage in the team building
process is called the Performing stage
this is the most productive stage for
the project team
in this stage team members manage
complex tasks and work toward the common
goals of the project
the leader employs a supervisory style
of management by overseeing progress
rewarding achievement and supervising
process
the team leader leads the project on
more or less an automated mode
when the project has completed
successfully or when the end is in sight
the team moves into the final stage
in the next screen we will discuss the
fifth stage adjourning
the last stage of team building is
called the adjourning stage in this
stage the project is winding down and
the goals are within reach the team
members are dealing with their impending
separation from the team the team leader
provides feedback to the team the leader
employs a supportive style of management
by giving feedback celebrating
accomplishments and providing closure
the team leader needs to adopt a
different style of leadership at every
stage
it is therefore important for a leader
to understand these stages and identify
the current stage that a team is in
the success of the team depends on how
well the leader can guide them through
these phases
in the next screen we will learn about
negative Dynamics
team members can exhibit negative
behavior in more than one way during the
Project Life Cycle this Behavior has a
negative effect on the Dynamics of the
team
the first kind of negative participants
fall in the category of overbearing
participants
these participants use their influence
or expertise to take on a position of
authority discounting contributions from
other team members
to cope with such participants team
leaders must establish ground rules for
participation and reinforce that the
group has the right to explore any area
pertinent to team goals and objectives
another kind of negative participant is
often referred to as the dominant
participant
these participants take up an excessive
amount of group Time by talking too much
focusing on trivial concerns and
otherwise preventing participation by
others
team leaders need to be able to control
dominant participants without inhibiting
their energy or enthusiasm
some other participants are reluctant
participants who feel intimidated and
are not happy with the team process
owing to their reluctance they miss
opportunities to bring up data that is
valuable to the project this can often
lead to hostility within the team one
way to deal with reluctant participants
is to respond positively and with
encouragement to any contribution from
the team member
teamwork is more than a natural
consequence of working together
team management is more than building a
relationship with individual team
members
all teams face group challenges that
need group-based diagnosis and problem
solving to ensure that negative
participants are able to contribute and
perform as part of the team
in the next screen we will learn about
group challenges
Six Sigma team and their
responsibilities are described here
various roles assist the smooth
execution of a Six Sigma project
these roles are required to support the
project by providing the information and
resources that are needed to execute the
project
the first important member of the Six
Sigma team is the executive sponsor
sponsors are the source or conduit for
project resources and they are usually
the recipients of the benefits the
project will produce
the sponsor is responsible for setting
the direction and priorities for the
organization
the sponsor may be a functional manager
or an external customer
the next important role is that of the
process owners they work with the black
belts to improve their respective
processes they provide functional
expertise about the process to the
project
usually this role is played by the
functional managers in charge of
specific processes
the next role in the project is that of
the champions
they are typically upper level managers
who control and allocate resources to
promote process improvements they ensure
the organization is providing necessary
resources to the project and the project
is fitting into the Strategic plans of
the organization
the first role related to the execution
of the project is the role of the master
black belt this role acts as a
consultant to team leaders and offers
expertise in the use of Six Sigma tools
and methodologies Master black belts are
experts in Six Sigma statistical tools
and are qualified to teach high-level
Six Sigma methodologies and applications
each Master black belt will have
multiple black belts under him
black belts are the leaders of
individual Six Sigma projects
they lead project teams and conduct the
detailed analysis required in Six Sigma
methodologies
black belts act as instructors and
mentors for green belts and educate them
in Six Sigma tools and methods they also
protect the interests of the project by
coordinating with functional managers
green belts are trained in Six Sigma but
typically lead project teams working in
their own areas of expertise
they are focused on the basic Six Sigma
tools for acceleration of projects green
belts work on projects on a part-time
basis dividing time between project and
functional responsibilities
an executive is the person who manages
and leads the team to ensure smooth
working of tasks and has the power to
execute decisions
a coach takes on a number of roles he or
she is the person who trains mentors
teaches and guides the team when
required
coach also motivates and builds
confidence of the members
a facilitator is a guide for the team or
group also known as a discussion leader
facilitators help the group or team to
understand their common objective and
plan their activities
a sponsor is a person who supports the
event or the project by providing all
the required resources
a team member is an individual who
belongs to a particular project team
a team member contributes to the
performance of the team and actively
participates for fulfillment of the
project objectives
the progress achievements and the
details of the project have to be
effectively communicated to the team
management customers and stakeholders
we will learn about modes of
communication in the next screen
let us understand communication within
the team in this screen the purpose of
communication within the team and the
modes of communication used are as
follows
meetings and emails are suitable to
communicate the roles and
responsibilities of the team members
meetings memos and emails are used by
the team to understand the project
status
workshops and meetings are conducted to
identify the outstanding tasks risks and
their corrective actions
team meetings assist decision making
and emails ensure coordination and
efficient work
the next screen will focus on
communication with stakeholders
the purpose of communication with
stakeholders and the modes of
communication used are as follows
meeting emails and events are suitable
to convey project objectives and goals
to stakeholders
meetings emails and newsletters assist
stakeholders in understanding project
status
workshops meetings and events help
stakeholders to identify the adverse
effects of a situation
meetings with stakeholders assist
decision-making process
in the next screen we will discuss the
communication technique
communication techniques can be grouped
in various ways the first grouping of
communication techniques is based on the
direction in which communication flows
vertical communication consists of two
subtypes namely downward flow of
communication and upward flow of
communication
in the downward flow of communication
the managers must pass information and
give orders and directives to the lower
levels in the organization
on the contrary upward communication
consists of information relayed from the
bottom or grassroot levels to the higher
levels of the company
horizontal communication refers to the
sharing of information across the same
levels of the organization
this can be in the form of formal and
informal communication
formal Communications are official
company sanctioned methods of
communicating to the employees the
Grapevine Rumor Mill Etc are some of the
means of informal communication in the
organization
the second grouping of communication
techniques is based on the usage of
words
verbal communication includes use of
words for communication via telephone
face to face Etc
non-verbal communication conveys
messages without the use of words
through body language facial expressions
Etc
the last grouping of communication
techniques is based on participation of
the people involved in communication
one-way communication happens when
information is relayed from the sender
to the receiver without the expectation
of a response like memos and
announcements
two-way communication is a method in
which both parties are involved in the
exchange of information
team tools are a part of the team
Dynamics and performance the various
team tools that are used are
brainstorming nominal group technique
and multi-voting if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
this lesson will cover the details of
the measure phase the key objective of
the measure phase is to gather as much
information as possible on the current
processes this involves three key tasks
that is creating a detailed process map
Gathering Baseline data and summarizing
and analyzing the data
let us understand process modeling in
the following screen
process modeling refers to the
visualization of a proposed system
layout or other change in the process
process modeling and simulation can
determine the effectiveness or
ineffectiveness of a new design or
process
they can be done using process mapping
and flowcharts we will learn about these
in the forthcoming screens
let us understand process mapping in
this screen process mapping refers to a
workflow diagram which gives a clear
understanding of the process or a series
of parallel processes
it is also known as process charting or
flow charting process mapping can be
done either in the measure phase or the
analyze phase the features of process
mapping are as follows
process mapping is usually the first
step in process improvement process
mapping gives a wider perspective of the
problems and opportunities for process
Improvement
it is a systematic way of recording all
the activities performed
process mapping can be done by using any
of the methods like flow charts written
procedures and detailed work
instructions
let us learn about flowchart in the
following screen
a flowchart is a pictorial
representation of all the steps of a
process in consecutive order it is used
to plan a project document processes and
communicate the process methodology with
others there are many symbols used in a
flowchart and the common symbols are
shown in the given table
it is recommended you take a look at the
symbols and their description for better
understanding
click the button to view an example of a
flowchart
the given flow chart shows the processes
involved in software development
the flowchart starts with the start box
which connects to the design box in a
software project a software design is
followed by coding which is Then
followed by testing
in The Next Step there is a check for
errors in case of Errors it is evaluated
for the error type
if it is a design error it goes back to
the beginning of the design stage if it
is not a design error it is then routed
to the beginning of the coding stage
on the contrary if there are no errors
the flowchart ends
let us learn about written procedures in
this screen a written procedure is a
step-by-step guide to direct The Reader
through a task it is used when the
process of a routine task is lengthy and
complex and it is essential for everyone
to strictly follow the rules written
procedures can also be used when you
want to know what is going on during
product or process development phases
there are a number of benefits of
documenting procedures
writing procedures help you avoid
mistakes and ensure consistency
they streamline the process and help
your employees take relevant decisions
and save a lot of time
written procedures help in improving
quality
they are simple to understand as they
tend to describe the processes at a
general level
in the next screen we will discuss how
work instructions are helpful in
understanding the process in detail
work instructions Define how one or more
activities involved in a procedure
should be written in a detailed manner
with the aid of technology or other
resources like flowcharts they provide
step-by-step details for a sequence of
activities organized in a logical format
so that an employee can follow it easily
and independently
for example in the internal audit
procedure how to fill out the audit
results report comes under work
instructions
selection of the three process mapping
tools is based on the amount of detail
involved in the process
for a less detailed process you can
select flowchart and for a detailed
process with lots of instructions you
can select work instructions
click the button to view an example of
work instructions
this example shows the work instructions
for shipping electronic instruments the
company name is Nutri worldwide Inc the
instructions are written by Brianna
Scott and approved by Andrew Murphy it
is a one-page instruction
the work instructions are documented for
the shipping of electronic instruments
by the shipping Department
the scope of the project states that it
is applicable to shipping operations
the procedure is divided into three
broad steps
as a first step the order for the
shipment must be prepared
in this step the shipping person
receives an order number from the sales
department through an automatic order
system the quantity of the instrument
and its card number are looked up from
the system file and the packaging is
done as per the instructions on the card
the next step is Packaging
special packing instructions must be
checked the instruments are then marked
as per the instructions on the card and
packed in a special or standard
container as per the requirement
the order number is written in the
shipping system and the packing list and
shipping documentation are obtained
finally the quantity of instruments and
the documents is checked
let us understand process input and
output variables in this screen
any Improvement of a process has a few
prerequisites
to improve a process the key process
output variables kpov and key process
input variables kpiv should first be
measured
metrics for key process variables
include percent defective operation cost
elapsed time backlog quantity and
documentation errors
critical variables are best identified
by the process owners
process owners know and understand each
step of a process and are in a better
position to identify the critical
variables initially
once identified the relationship between
the variables is depicted using tools
such as cypok and cause and effect
Matrix
the process input variables results are
compared to determine which input
variables have the greatest effect on
the output variables
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will discuss
probability and statistics in detail let
us learn about probability in the
following screen
probability refers to the chance of
something occurring or happening an
outcome is the result of a single trial
of an experiment
Suppose there are n possible outcomes
that are equally likely
the probability that a specific type of
event or outcome say F can occur is the
number of specific outcomes divided by
the total possible outcomes
click the button to view an example of
probability
in the event of tossing a coin what is
the probability of the occurrence of
heads
a single trial of tossing a coin has two
outcomes heads and tails hence the
probability of heads occurring is one
divided by two the total number of
outcomes
let us look at some basic properties of
probability in this screen there are
three basic properties of probability
click each property to know more
property 1 states that the probability
of an event is always between 0 and 1
both inclusive
according to Property 2 the probability
of an event that cannot occur is zero in
other words an event that cannot occur
is called an impossible event
property 3 states that the probability
of an event that must occur is one in
other words an event that must occur is
called a certain event
if e is an event then the probability of
its occurrence is given by P of e it is
also read as the probability of event e
in this screen let us look at some
common terms used in probability along
with an example
the commonly used terms improbability
are sample space Venn diagram and event
sample space is the collection of all
possible outcomes for a given experiment
in the coin example discussed earlier
the sample space consists of one
instance each of heads and tails if two
coins are tossed the sample space would
be four in total a Venn diagram shows
all hypothetically possible logical
relations between a finite collection of
sets an event is a collection of
outcomes for an experiment which is any
subset of the sample space
click the button to view an example of
probability
what is the probability of getting a 3
followed by two when a dice is thrown
twice
when the dice is thrown twice the first
row can't have any number from one to
six
similarly the second row can also have
any number from one to six so the total
sample space is six times six that is
36.
the event in this case is three followed
by two this can happen in only one way
so the probability in the question is
one divided by thirty six
let us discuss the basic concepts of
probability in this screen
some basic concepts of probability are
independent event dependent event
mutually exclusive and mutually
inclusive events
click each concept to know more
when the probability of occurrence of an
event does not affect the probability of
occurrence of another event the two
events are said to be independent
suppose you roll the dice and flipped a
coin at the same time
the probability of getting any number on
the dice in no way influences the
probability of getting heads or tails on
the coin
when the probability of one event
occurring influences the likelihood of
the other event the events are said to
be dependent
events are said to be mutually exclusive
if the occurrence of any one of them
prevents the occurrence of all the
others in other words only one event can
occur at a time
consider an example of flipping a coin
when you flip a coin you will either get
heads or tails but not both
you can add the probabilities of these
two events to prove they aren't mutually
exclusive
any two events wherein one event cannot
occur without the other are said to be
mutually inclusive events
in this screen let us learn about the
multiplication rules also known as and
rules the multiplication rules or and
rules depend on the event dependency for
independent events that is if two events
are independent of each other the
special multiplication rule applies for
mutually independent events the special
multiplication rule is as follows
if the events a b c and so on are
independent of each other then the
probability of A and B and C and so on
is equal to the product of their
individual probabilities
click the button to view an example of
this rule
Suppose there are three events which are
independent of each other such as the
event of flipping a coin and getting
heads drawing a card and getting an Ace
and throwing a dice and getting a one
what is the probability of occurrence of
all these events
the answer is the probability of A and B
and C is equal to the product of their
individual probabilities
which is half multiplied by 1 13
multiplied by 1 6. the result is
0.0064 which is 0.64 percent
hence there is 0.64 percent probability
of all of the events occurring
we will continue the discussion on
multiplication rules in this screen
the multiplication rule for
non-independent or conditional events
which is also the general multiplication
rule is as follows
if a and b are two events then the
probability of A and B is equal to the
product of probability of a and the
probability of B given a alternatively
we can say that for any two events their
joint probability is equal to the
probability that one of these events
occurs multiplied with the conditional
probability of the other event given the
first event click the button to view an
example of this rule
a bag contains six golden coins and four
silver coins two coins are drawn without
replacement from the bag
what is the probability that both of the
coins are silver let a be the event that
the first coin is silver and B be the
event that the second coin is silver
there are 10 coins in the bag four of
which are silver therefore P of a equals
four divided by ten
after the first election there are nine
coins in the bag three of which are
silver therefore P of B given a equals
three divided by nine
therefore based on the rule of
multiplication probability of a
intersection b equals four divided by
ten multiplied by three divided by nine
the answer is twelve divided by ninety
which is
0.1334 hence there is 13 percent
probability that both the coins are
silver
in this screen we will look at the
definitions and formula of permutation
and combination
permutation is the total number of ways
in which a set group or number of things
can be arranged
the order matters to a great extent in
permutation
the manner in which the objects or
numbers are arranged will be considered
in permutation
the formula for permutation is NPR
equals P of N and R equals n factorial
divided by n minus r factorial
where n is the number of objects and R
is the number of objects taken at a time
the unordered arrangement of set group
or number of things is known as
combination
the order does not matter in combination
the formula for combination is NCR
equals c of N and R equals n factorial
divided by R factorial multiplied by n
minus r factorial where n is the number
of objects and R is the number of
objects taken at a time
let us look at an example for
calculating permutation and combination
in the following screen
from a group of 10 employees a company
has to select four for a particular
project
in how many ways can the selection
happen given the following conditions
when the arrangements of employees needs
to be different when the arrangement of
employees need not be different
click the button to know the answer
in the given example the values of N and
R are 10 and 4 respectively
let us consider the first condition
from a group of 10 employees four
employees need to be selected the
arrangement needs to be different
using the permutation formula NPR equals
P of N and R equals n factorial divided
by n minus r factorial
10p4 equals P of 10 and 4 equals 10
factorial divided by 10 minus 4
factorial equals 5040.
therefore the four employees can be
selected in 5040 ways
let us now consider the second condition
from a group of 10 employees four
employees need to be selected
the arrangement of employees need not be
different
using the combination formula NCR equals
c of N and R equals n factorial divided
by R factorial multiplied by n minus r
factorial
10 C4 equals c of 10 and 4 equals 10
factorial divided by 4 factorial
multiplied by 10 minus 4 factorial
equals 210.
therefore the four employees can be
selected from a group of 10 employees in
210 different ways
let us understand the two types of
Statistics in this screen
statistics refers to the science of
collection analysis interpretation and
presentation of data insect Sigma
statistical methods and principles are
used to measure and analyze the process
performance and improvements
there are two major types of Statistics
descriptive statistics and inferential
statistics
descriptive statistics is also known as
enumerative statistics and inferential
statistics is also known as analytical
statistics
descriptive statistics include
organizing summarizing and presenting
the data in a meaningful way whereas
inferential statistics includes making
inferences and drawing conclusions from
the data descriptive statistics
describes what's going on in the data
the main objective of inferential
statistics is to make inferences from
the data to more General conditions
histograms pie charts box plots
frequency distributions and measures of
central tendency mean median and mode
are all examples of descriptive
statistics on the other hand examples of
inferential statistics are hypothesis
testing scatter diagrams Etc
the main objective of statistical
inference is to draw conclusions on
population characteristics based on the
information available in the sample
collecting data from a population is not
always easy especially if the size of
the population is big
the easier way is to collect a sample
from the population and from the sample
statistic collected make an assessment
about the population parameter
click the button to see an example of
statistical inference
the management team of a qriket council
wants to know if the team's performance
has improved after recruiting a new
coach
the management conducts a test to prove
this statistically let us consider y a
and Y B where y a stands for efficiency
of Coach a and YB stands for efficiency
of Coach B
to conduct the test the basic assumption
is coach a and Coach B are both
effective this basic assumption is known
as null hypothesis
here let us assume the status quo is
null hypothesis hence null hypothesis h0
can be given by y a equals YB
the management team also challenges
their basic assumption by assuming the
coaches are not equally effective this
is their alternate hypothesis
the alternate hypothesis states that the
efficiencies of the two coaches differ
if the null hypothesis is proven wrong
the alternate hypothesis must be right
hence alternate hypothesis H1 can be
given y a is not equal to y b
these hypothesis statements are used in
a hypothesis test which will be
discussed in the later part of the
course
in this screen we will learn about the
types of errors when collecting data
from a population as a sample and
forming a conclusion on the population
based on the sample you run into the
risk of committing errors
there are two possible errors that can
happen type 1 error and type 2 error the
type 1 error occurs when the null
hypothesis is rejected when it is in
fact true
type 1 error is also known as producer's
risk
the chance of committing a type 1 error
is known as Alpha
alpha or significance level is the
chance of committing a type 1 error and
is typically chosen to be five percent
this means the maximum amount of risk
you have for committing a type 1 error
is five percent
let us consider the previous example
arriving at a conclusion that Coach B is
better than coach a when in fact they
are at the same level is a type 1 error
the risk you have of committing this
error is five percent which means there
is a five percent chance your experiment
can give wrong results the type 2 error
occurs when the null hypothesis is
accepted when it is in fact false also
when you reject the alternate hypothesis
when it is actually true you commit a
type 2 error type 2 error is also
referred to as consumer's risk in
comparing the two coaches the coaches
were actually different in their
efficiencies but the conclusion was that
they are the same the chance of
committing a type 2 error is known as
beta the maximum chance of committing a
type 2 error is 20 percent
in the next screen we will learn about
Central limit theorem
Central limit theorem CLT states that
for a sample size greater than 30 the
sample mean is very close to the
population mean in simple words the
sample mean approaches the normal
distribution
for example if you have sample 1 and its
mean is mean one sample two and its mean
is mean to and so on take the means of
mean one mean to Etc and you will find
that it is the same as the population
mean
population mean is the average of the
sample means
in such cases the standard error of mean
also known as sem that represents the
variability between the sample means is
very less
the SCM is often used to represent the
standard deviation of the sample
the formula for sem is population
standard deviation divided by the square
root of the sample size
selecting a sample size also depends on
the concept called Power also known as
power of the test
we will cover this concept in detail in
the later part of the course
let us look at the graphical
representation of the central limit
theorem in the following screen
the plot of the three numbers two three
and four looks as shown in the graph it
is interesting to note that the total
number of times each digit is chosen is
six when the plot of the sample mean of
nine samples of size 2 each is drawn it
looks like the red line which is plotted
in the figure the x-axis shows numbers
of the mean which are 2 2.5 3 and 4. on
the y-axis the frequency is plotted the
point at which arrows from number two
and three converge is the mean of two
and three similarly the point at which
arrows from two and four converge is the
mean of the numbers two and four
let us discuss the concluding points of
the central limit theorem in the next
screen
the central limit theorem concludes that
the sampling distributions are helpful
in dealing with non-normal data if you
take the sample data points from a
population and plot the distribution of
the means of the sample you get the
sampling distribution of the means the
mean of the sampling distribution also
known as the mean of means will be equal
to the population mean
also the sampling distribution
approaches normality as the sample size
increases
note that CLT enables you to draw
inferences from the sample statistics
about the population parameters this is
irrespective of the distribution of the
population
CLT also becomes the basis for
calculating confidence interval for
hypothesis tests as it allows the use of
a standard normal table
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will cover the concept
of statistical distributions
let us start with discrete probability
distribution in the following screen
discrete probability distribution is
characterized by the probability Mass
function it is important to be familiar
with discrete distributions while
dealing with discrete data some of the
examples of discrete probability
distribution are binomial distribution
poisson distribution negative binomial
distribution geometric distribution and
hypergeometric distribution
we will focus only on the two most
useful discrete distributions binomial
distribution and poisson distribution
like most probability distributions
these distributions also help in
predicting the sample behavior that has
been observed in a population
let us learn about binomial distribution
in the following screen
binomial distribution is a probability
distribution for discrete data named
after the Swiss mathematician Jacob
Bernoulli it is an application of
popular knowledge to predict the sample
Behavior
binomial distribution also describes the
discrete data as a result of a
particular process like the tossing of a
coin for a fixed number of times and the
success or failure in an interview a
process is known as Bernoulli's process
when the process output has only two
possible values like defective or OK
pass or fail and yes or no
binomial distribution is used to deal
with defective items defect is any
non-compliance with a specification
defective is a product or service with
at least one defect
binomial distribution is most suitable
when the sample size is less than 30 and
less than 10 percent of the population
it is the percentage of non-defective
items provided the probability of
creating a defective item Remains the
Same over a period let us look at the
equation
the probability of exactly our successes
out of a sample size of n is denoted by
P of R which is equal to NCR whole
multiplied by P to the power of R and 1
minus P whole to the power of n minus r
in the equation p is the probability of
success R is the number of successes
desired and N is the sample size
to continue discussing the binomial
distribution let us look at some of its
key calculations in the following screen
the mean of a binomial distribution is
denoted by Mio and is given by n
multiplied by P the standard deviation
of a binomial distribution is denoted by
Sigma which is equal to n multiplied by
P multiplied by 1 minus p
the method of calculating factorials say
a factorial of 5 is the product of five
four three two and one which is equal to
120.
similarly factorial of 4 is the product
of four three two and one which is equal
to 24. let us look at an example of
calculating binomial distribution in the
next screen
suppose you wish to know the probability
of getting heads five times in eight
coin tosses you can use the binomial
equation for the same
click the answer button to see how this
is done
the tossing of a coin has only two
outcomes heads and tails it means that
the probability of each outcome is 0.5
and it remains fixed over a period of
time Additionally the outcomes are
statistically independent
in this case the probability of success
denoted by P is 0.5 the number of
successes desired is denoted by R which
is 5 and the sample size is denoted by n
which is 8. the therefore the
probability of five heads is equal to
factorial of 8 CR which is eight divided
by a factorial of 5 and factorial of
eight minus five whole multiplied by 0.5
to the power of 5 multiplied by one
minus 0.5 whole to the power of eight
minus five
this calculation gives a result of
0.2187 which is equal to
21.87 percent let us learn about poisson
distribution in this screen
poisson distribution is named after
Simeon Denis poisson and is also used
for discrete data
poisson distribution is an application
of the population knowledge to predict
the sample Behavior it is generally used
for describing the probability
distribution of an event with respect to
time or space
some of the characteristics of poisson
distribution are as follows
croissant distribution describes the
discrete data resulting from a process
like the number of calls received by a
call center agent or the number of
accidents at a signal
unlike binomial distribution which deals
with binary discrete data The Zone
distribution deals with integers which
can take any value poisson distribution
is suitable for analyzing situations
wherein the number of Trials similar to
the sample size in binomial distribution
is large and tends towards Infinity
additionally it is used in situations
where the probability of success in each
trial is very small almost tending
towards zero this is the reason why
poisson distribution is applicable for
predicting the occurrence of rare events
like plane crashes car accidents Etc and
is therefore widely used in the
insurance sector poisson distribution
can be used for predicting the number of
defects as well given a low defect
occurrence rate
let us look at the formula for
calculating poisson distribution in the
next screen
the poisson distribution for a
probability of exactly X occurrences is
given by P of x equals 2 Lambda to the
power of X multiplied with log e to the
power of minus Lambda whole divided by
factorial of X in this equation Lambda
is the mean number of occurrences during
the interval X is the number of
occurrences desired and E is the base of
natural logarithm which is equal to
2.71828
the mean of the poisson distribution is
given by the Lambda and the standard
deviation of a poisson distribution is
given by Sigma which is the square root
of Lambda
let us look at an example to calculate
poisson distribution in the next screen
the past records of a road Junction
which is accident prone show a mean
number of five accidents per week at
this Junction assume that the number of
accidents follows up with song
distribution and calculate the
probability of any number of accidents
happening in a week
click the button to know the answer
given the situation you know that the
value of Lambda or mean is 5. so P of 0
that is the probability of zero
accidents per week is calculated as 5 to
the power of zero multiplied by e to the
power of minus five whole divided by a
factorial of zero the answer is
0.006 applying the same formula the
probability of one accident per week is
0.03 the probability of more than two
accidents per week is one minus the sum
of probabilities of zero one and two
accidents which is
0.884 in other words the probability is
88.4 percent
let us learn about normal distribution
in this screen
the normal or gaussian distribution is a
continuous probability distribution the
normal distribution is represented as n
and depends on two factors mu which
stands for mean and sigma which gives
the standard deviation of the data
points normal distribution normally has
a higher frequency of values around the
mean and lesser occurrences away from it
it is often used as a first
approximation to describe real valued
random variables that tend to Cluster
around a single mean value
the distribution is bell-shaped and
symmetrical the total area under the
normal curve is one which is p of X
various types of data such as body
weight height the output of a
manufacturing device Etc follow the
normal distribution additionally normal
distribution is continuous and
symmetrical with the tails asymptotic to
the x-axis which means they touch the
x-axis at Infinity
let us continue to discuss normal
distribution in the following screen
in a normal distribution to standardize
comparisons of dispersion or the
different measurement units like inches
meters grams Etc a standard Z variable
is used the uses of Z value are as
follows while the value of Z or the
number of standard deviations is unique
for each probability within the normal
distribution it helps in finding
probabilities of data points anywhere
within the distribution
it is dimensionless as well that is it
has no units such as millimeters liters
coulombs Etc
there are different formulas to arrive
at the normal distribution we will focus
on one commonly used formula for
calculating normal distribution which is
z equals y minus mu whole divided by
Sigma here Z is the number of standard
deviations between Y and the mean
denoted by mu Y is the value of the data
point in concern mu is mean of the
population or data points and sigma is
the standard deviation of the population
or data points let us look at an example
for calculating normal distribution in
the following screen
suppose the time taken to resolve
customer problems follows a normal
distribution with a mean of 250 hours
and standard deviation of 23 hours find
the probability of a problem resolution
taking more than 300 hours click the
button to know the answer
in this case Y is equal to 300 mu equals
250 and sigma equals 23. applying the
normal distribution formula Z is equal
to 300 minus 250 whole divided by 23.
the result is 2.17 when you look at the
normal distribution table the Z value of
2.17 covers an area of
0.98499 under itself
this means the probability of a problem
taking zero to three hundred hours to be
resolved is 98.5 percent and therefore
the chances of a problem resolution
taking more than 300 hours is 1.5
percent
let us understand the usage of Z table
in this screen
the graphical representation of Z table
usage is given here
the probability of areas under the curve
is one
for the actual value one can identify
the z-score by using the Z table
as shown this probability is the area
under the curve to the left of point
plus a to zero
using the actual data when you calculate
mean and standard deviation and the
values are 25 and 5 respectively it is
the normal distribution
if the same data is standardized to a
mean value of zero and standard
deviation value of one it is the
standard normal distribution
in the next screen we will take a look
at the Z table
the Z table gives the probability that Z
is between 0 and a positive number there
are different forms of normal
distribution Z tables followed globally
the most common form of Z table with
positive z-scores is shown here
the value of a called the percentage
point is given along the borders of the
table in bold and is to two decimal
places
the values in the main table are the
probabilities that Z is between 0 and
plus a
note that the values running down the
table are to one decimal place
the numbers along the column change only
for the second decimal place
let us look at some examples on how to
use a z table in the following screen
let us find the value of P of Z Less
Than Zero
the table is not needed to find the
answer once we know that the variable Z
takes a value less than or equal to zero
first the area under the curve is one
and second the curve is symmetrical
about Z equals zero hence there is 0.5
or 50 above chance of Z equals 0 and 0.5
or 50 below chance of Z equals zero
let us find the value of P of Z greater
than 1.12
. in this case the chance of Z is
greater than a number in this case 1.12
you can find this by using the following
fact
the opposite or complement of an event
of a is the event of not a that is the
opposite or complement of event a
occurring is the event a not occurring
its probability is given by P of not
equal a equals 1 minus P of a
in other words P of Z greater than 1.12
is 1 minus the opposite which is p of Z
lesser than 1.12
using the table P of Z less than 1.12
equals 0.5 plus P of 0 less than Z less
than 1.12 equals 0.5 plus
0.3686 which is 0.8686
hence the answer is p of Z greater than
1.12 equals 1 minus
0.8686 which is
0.1314 note the answer is less than 0.5
let us find the value of P of Z lies
between 0 and 1.12
in this case where Z Falls within an
interval the probability can be read
straight off the table
P of Z lies between 0 and 1.12 equals
0.3686 we will learn about chi-square
distribution in this screen
chi-squared distribution is also known
as Chi Squared or chi-square
distribution
Chi Squared with K minus 1 degrees of
freedom is the distribution of a sum of
the squares of K independent standard
normal random variables
the chi-square distribution is one of
the most widely used probability
distributions in inferential statistics
it is also known as hypothesis testing
and the distribution is used in
hypothesis tests when used in hypothesis
tests it only needs one sample for the
test to be conducted
conventionally degree of freedom is K
minus one where K is the sample size
for example if w x y and z are four
random variables with standard normal
distributions then the random variable F
which is the sum of w Square x square y
square and Z square has a chi-square
distribution
the degrees of the freedom of the
distribution DF equals the number of
normally distributed variables used in
this case DF is equal to four
let us look at the formula to calculate
chi-squared distribution in the
following screen
chi-square calculated or Sigma or the
chi-square index equals F of O minus F
of e whole Square divided by F of E
here F of O stands for an observed
frequency and F of e stands for an
expected frequency determined through a
contingency table
let us understand T distribution in the
next screen
the T distribution method is the most
appropriate method to be used in the
following situations
when you have a sample size of less than
30 when the population standard
deviation is not known when the
population is approximately normal
unlike the normal distribution a t
distribution is lower at the mean and
higher at the Tails as seen in the image
T distribution is used for hypothesis
testing
also as seen in the image the T
distribution is symmetrical in shape but
flatter than the normal distribution
as the sample size increases the
t-distribution approaches normality
for every possible sample size or
degrees of freedom there is a different
T distribution
let us learn about F distribution in the
following screen
the F distribution is a ratio of two
chi-squared distributions a specific F
distribution is denoted by the ratio of
the degrees of freedom for the numerator
chi-square and the degrees of freedom
for the denominator chi-square
the f-test is performed to calculate and
observe if the standard deviations or
variances of two processes are
significantly different
the project teams are usually concerned
about reducing the process variance as
per the formula f calculated equals S1
Square divided by S2 Square where S1 and
S2 are the standard deviations of the
two samples
if the F calculated is one it implies
there is no difference in the variance
if S1 is greater than S2 then the
numerator must be greater than the
denominator in other words df1 equals N1
minus 1 and df2 equals N2 minus 1. from
the F distribution table you can easily
find out the critical F distribution at
Alpha and the degrees of freedom of the
samples of two different processes df1
and df2 let us proceed to the next topic
of this lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will discuss collecting
and summarizing data in detail let us
learn about types of data in the
following screen
data is objective information which
everyone can agree on it is a collection
of facts from which conclusions may be
drawn the two types of data are
attribute data and variable data click
each type to know more
this great data is data that can be
counted and only includes numbers such
as 2 4050.
attribute data is commonly called pass
fail or good bad data
attribute or discrete data cannot be
broken down into a smaller unit
meaningfully it answers questions such
as how many how often or what type
some examples of attribute data are
number of defective products percentage
of defective products frequency at which
a machine is repaired or the type of
award received
any data that can be measured on a
continuous scale is continuous or
variable data this type of data answers
questions such as how long what volume
or how far examples of continuous data
include height weight time taken to
complete a task temperature and so on
let us understand the importance of
selecting the data type in this screen
deciding the data type facilitates
analysis and interpretation
therefore the first step in the measure
phase is to determine what type of data
should be collected this can be done by
considering the following
the first consideration is to identify
what is already known
for this the values already identified
for the process are listed
these include critical to Quality
parameters or ctqs key process output
variables or kpovs and the key process
input variable or kpivs next to
understand how to proceed with the data
gathered it is necessary to determine
the data type that fits the metrics for
the key variables identified
the question now arises why should the
data type be identified
this is important as it enables the
right set of data to be collected
analyzed and used to draw inferences
it is not advisable to convert one type
of data into another converting
attribute data to variable data is
difficult and requires assumptions to be
made about the process
it may also require additional data
Gathering including retesting units
let us look at measurement scales in the
following screen
there are four measurement scales
arranged in the table in increasing
order of their statistical desirability
in the nominal scale the data consists
of only names or categories and there is
no possibility of ordering
an example of this type of measurement
can be a bag of colored balls which
contains 10 green balls five black balls
eight yellow balls and nine white balls
this is the least informative of all
scales the most appropriate measure of
central tendency for this scale is mode
in the ordinal or ranking scale data is
arranged in order and values can be
compared with each other
an example of this scale can be the
ratings given to different restaurants
three for a five for B two for C and
four for d
the central tendency for this scale is
median or mode the interval scale is
used for ranking items in Step order
along a scale of equidistant points for
example the temperatures of three metal
rods are 100 degrees 200 degrees and 600
degrees Fahrenheit respectively note
that 3 times 200 degrees is not the same
as 600 Degrees as a temperature
measurement
the central tendency here is mean median
or mode
mean is used if the data does not have
any outliers
the ratio scale represents variable data
and is measured against a known standard
or increment however this scale also has
an absolute zero that is no numbers
exist below zero an example of the ratio
scale are physical measures where height
weight and electric charge represent
ratio scale data note that negative
length is not possible again here you
would use mean median or mode as the
central tendency measure
in the next screen we will learn about
assuring data accuracy
to ensure data is accurate sampling
techniques are used sampling is the
process act or technique of selecting an
appropriate test group or sample from a
larger population
it is preferable to survey 100 people to
surveying 10 000 people
sampling saves the time money and effort
involved in collecting data
the three types of sampling techniques
described here are random sampling
sequential sampling and stratified
sampling
click each type to know more
random sampling is the technique where a
group of subjects or a sample for study
is selected from a larger group or
population at random
sequential sampling is similar to
multiple sampling plans except that it
can in theory continue indefinitely
in other words it is a non-probability
sampling technique wherein the
researcher picks a single subject or a
group of subjects in a given time
interval conducts the study analyzes the
results and then picks another group of
subjects if needed and so on
in stratified sampling the idea is to
take samples from subgroups of a
population
this technique gives an accurate
estimate of the population parameter
in this screen we will compare simple
random sampling with stratified sampling
simple random sampling is easy to do
while stratified sampling takes a lot of
time
the possibility of simple random
sampling giving erroneous results is
very high while stratified sampling
minimizes the chances of error
simple random sampling doesn't have the
power to show possible causes of
variation while stratified sampling if
done correctly will show assignable
causes
in the next screen we will look at the
check sheet method of collecting data
the process of collecting data is
expensive wrongly collected data leading
to wrong analysis and inferences results
in resources being wasted
a check sheet is a structured form
prepared to collect and analyze data it
is a generic tool that is relatively
simple to use and can be adopted for a
variety of purposes
check sheets are used when the data can
be observed and collected repeatedly by
the same person or at the same location
they are also used while collecting data
from a production process
a common example is calculating the
number of absentees in a company
the table shows absentee data collected
for a week
we will discuss data coding and its
advantages in the following screen
data coding is a process of converting
and condensing raw data into categories
and sets so that the data can be used
for further analysis the benefits of
data coding are listed here
data coding simplifies the large
quantity of data that is collected from
sources the large amount of data makes
analysis and drawing conclusions
difficult
it leads to chaos and ambiguity
data coding simplifies the data by
coding it into variables and then
categorizing these variables
raw data cannot be easily entered into
computers for analysis data coding is
used to convert raw data into process
data that can be easily fed into
Computing systems for calculation and
Analysis
coding of data makes it easy to analyze
the data converted data can either be
analyzed directly or fed into computers
the analyst can easily draw conclusions
when all the data is categorized and
computerized
data coding also enables organized
representation of data division of data
into categories helps organize large
chunks of information thus making
analysis and interpretation easier data
coding also ensures that data repetition
does not occur and duplicate entries are
eliminated so that the final result is
not affected in the following screen we
will discuss measures of central
tendency of the descriptive statistics
in detail
a measure of central tendency is a
single value that indicates the central
point in a set of data and helps in
identifying data Trends the three most
commonly used measures of the central
tendency are mean median and mode
click each measure to know more
mean is the most common measure of
central tendency it is the sum of all
the data values divided by the number of
data points
also called arithmetic mean or average
it is the most widely used measure of
central tendency
also known as positional mean median is
the number present in the middle of the
data set when the numbers are arranged
in ascending or descending order
if the data set has an even number of
entries then the median is the mean of
the two middle numbers
median can also be calculated by the
formula n plus 1 divided by two where n
is the number of entries
mode also known as frequency mean is the
value that occurs most frequently in a
set of data data sets that have more
than one mode are known as bimodal data
let us look at an example for
determining mean median and mode in this
screen
the data set has the numbers one two
three four five five six seven and eight
click the button to know the answer
as previously defined mean is the sum of
all the data items divided by the number
of items therefore the mean is equal to
41 divided by 9 which is equal to 4.56
the number in the middle of the data set
is five therefore the median is five
mode is the most frequently occurring
number which is again five
in this screen we will understand the
effect of outliers on the data set
let us consider a minor change to the
data set a new number 100 is added to
the data set
on using the same formula to calculate
mean the new mean is 15.11 ideally 50
percent of values should lie on either
side of the mean value
however in this example it can be seen
that almost 90 percent of values lie
below the mean value of 15.11 and only
one value above the mean
the data point 100 is called an outlier
an outlier is an extreme value in the
data set that skews the mean value to
one side of the data set
note that the median remains unchanged
at five therefore mean is not an
appropriate measure of central tendency
if the data has outliers median is
preferred in this case
in the next screen we will look at
measures of dispersion of the
descriptive statistics
apart from central tendency another
important parameter to describe a data
set is spread or dispersion contrary to
the measures of central tendency such as
mean median and mode measures of
dispersion Express the spread of values
higher the variation of data points
higher the spread of the data
the three main measures of dispersion
are range variance and standard
deviation we will discuss each of these
in the upcoming screens
let us start with the first measure of
dispersion range
the range of a particular set of data is
defined as the difference between the
largest and smallest values of the data
in the example the largest value of the
data is nine and the smallest value is
one therefore the range is nine minus
one eight in calculating range all the
data points are not needed and only the
maximum and minimum values are required
let us understand the next measure of
dispersion variance in the following
screen
the variance denoted as Sigma square or
S square is defined as the average of
squared mean differences and shows the
variation in a data set to calculate the
variance for a sample data set of 10
numbers type the numbers in an Excel
sheet calculate the variance using the
formula equals varp or vars
the varp formula gives the population
variance which is 7.24 for this example
the vars formula gives the sample
variance 8.04
population variance is calculated when
the data set is for the entire
population and Sample variance is
calculated when data is available only
for a sample of the population
population variance is preferred over
sample variance as the latter is only an
estimate
sample variance allows for a broader
range of possible answers for the true
mean of the population
that is the confidence levels are higher
in Sample variance
note that variance is a measure of
variation and cannot be considered as
the variation in a data set
in the following screen we will
understand the next measure of
dispersion standard deviation
standard deviation denoted by Sigma or S
is given by the square root of variance
the statistical notation of this is
given on screen
standard deviation is the most important
measure of dispersion
standard deviation is always relative to
the mean
for the same data set the population
standard deviation is 2.69
and Sample standard deviation is 2.83 as
in variance calculation if the data set
is measured for every unit in a
population the population standard
deviation and Sample standard deviation
can be calculated in Excel using the
formula given on the screen
the steps to manually calculate the
standard deviation are
first calculate the mean then calculate
the difference between each data point
and the mean and square that answer
next calculate the sum of the squares
next divide the sum of the squares by n
or n minus 1 to find the variance lastly
find the square root of variance which
gives the standard deviation
in the next screen we will look at
frequency distribution of the
descriptive statistics
frequency distribution is a method of
grouping data into mutually exclusive
categories showing the number of
observations in each class an example is
presented to demonstrate frequency
distribution a survey was conducted
among the residents of a particular area
to collect data on cars owned by each
home a total of 20 homes were surveyed
to create a frequency table for the
results collected in the survey the
first step is to divide the results into
intervals and count the number of
results in each interval
for instance in this example the
intervals would be the number of
households with no car one car two cars
and so on
next a table is created with separate
columns for the intervals the tallied
results for each interval and the number
of occurrences or frequency of results
in each interval
each result for a given interval is
recorded with a tally mark in the second
column the tally marks for each interval
are added and the sum is entered in the
frequency column
the frequency table allows viewing
distribution of data across a set of
values at a glance
in the following screen we will look at
cumulative frequency distribution
a cumulative frequency distribution
table is similar to the frequency
distribution table only more detailed
there are additional columns for
cumulative frequency percentage and
cumulative percentage
in the cumulative frequency column the
cumulative frequency or the previous row
or rows is added to the current row the
percentage is calculated by dividing the
frequency by the total number of results
and multiplying by 100 the cumulative
percentage is calculated similar to the
cumulative frequency
let us look at an example for cumulative
frequency distribution
the ages of all the participants in a
chess tournament are recorded the lowest
age is 37 and the highest is 91.
keeping intervals of 10 the lowest
interval starts with the lower limit as
35 and the upper limit as 44.
similar intervals are created until an
upper limit of 94.
in the frequency column the number of
times a result appears in a particular
interval is recorded in the cumulative
frequency column the cumulative
frequency of the previous row is added
to the frequency of the current row
for the first row the cumulative
frequency is the same as the frequency
in the second row the cumulative
frequency is one plus two which is three
and so on
in the percentage column the percentage
of the frequency is listed by dividing
the frequency by the total number of
results which is 10 and multiplying the
value by 100.
for instance in the first row the
frequency is one and the number of
results is 10. therefore the percentage
is 10. the final column is the
cumulative percentage column in this
column the cumulative frequency is
divided by the total number of results
which is 10 and the value is multiplied
by hundred note that the last number in
this column should be equal to 100. in
this example the cumulative frequency is
one and the total number of results is
10. therefore the cumulative percentage
of the first row is 10. let us look at
the stem and leaf plots which is one of
the graphical methods of understanding
distribution
graphical methods are extremely useful
tools to understand how data is
distributed sometimes merely by looking
at the data distribution errors in a
process can be identified
the stem and leaf method is a convenient
method of manually plotting data sets it
is used for presenting data in a
graphical format to assist visualizing
the shape of a given distribution
in the example on the screen the
temperatures in Fahrenheit for the month
of May are given
to collate this information in a stem
and leaf plot all the tens digits are
entered in the stem column and all the
units digits against each tens digit are
entered in the leaf column to start with
the lowest value is considered in this
case the lowest temperature is 51. in
the first row five is entered in the
stem column and zero in the leaf column
the next lowest temperature is 58. 8 is
entered in the leaf column corresponding
to 5 in the stem
the next number is 59. all the
temperatures falling in the 50s are
similarly entered
in the next row the same process is
repeated for temperatures in the 60s
this is continued till all the
temperature values are entered in the
table
let us understand another graphical
method in the next screen box and
whisker plots
a box and whisker graph based on medians
or quartiles is used to display a data
set in a way that allows viewing the
distribution of the data points easily
consider the following example the
lengths of 13 fish caught in a lake were
measured and recorded the data set is
given on the screen
the first step to draw a box and whisker
plot is therefore to arrange the numbers
in increasing order
next find the median as there is an odd
number of data entries the median is the
number in the middle of the data set
which in this case is 12. the next step
is to find the lower median or quartile
this is the median of the lower six
numbers the middle of these numbers is
halfway between eight and nine which
would be 8.5
similarly the upper median or quartile
is located for the upper six numbers to
the right of the median the upper median
is halfway between the two values 14 and
14. therefore the upper median is 14.
let us now understand how the box and
whisker chart is drawn using the values
of the median and upper and lower
quartiles
the next step is a numbered line is
drawn extending far enough to include
all the data points
then a vertical line is drawn from the
median point 12. the lower and upper
quartiles 8.5 and 14 respectively are
marked with vertical lines and these are
joined with the median line to form two
boxes as shown on the screen
next two whiskers are extended from
either ends of the boxes as shown to the
smallest and largest numbers in the data
set 5 and 20 respectively
the box and whiskers graph is now
complete the following inferences can be
drawn from the box and whisker plot the
lengths of the fish range from 5 to 20.
the range is therefore 15.
the quartiles split the data into four
equal parts in other words one quarter
of the data numbers is less than 8.5 one
quarter between 8.5 and 12 next quarter
of the data numbers are between 12 and
14. and another quarter has data numbers
greater than 14.
in this screen we will learn about
another graphical method scatter
diagrams
a scattered diagram or scatter plot is a
tool used to analyze the relationship or
correlation between two sets of
variables X and Y with X as the
independent variable and Y as the
dependent variable
a scatter diagram is also useful when
cause effect relationships have to be
examined or root causes have to be
identified
there are five different types of
correlation that can be used in a
scatter diagram
let us learn about them in the next
screen
the five types of correlation are
perfect positive correlation moderate
positive correlation no relation or no
correlation moderate negative
correlation and perfect negative
correlation
click each type to learn more
in perfect positive correlation the
value of dependent variable y increases
proportionally with any increase in the
value of independent variable X
this is said to be one is to one that is
any change in one variable results in an
equal amount of change in the other
the following example is presented to
demonstrate perfect positive correlation
the consumption of milk is found to
increase proportionally with an increase
in the consumption of coffee
the data is presented in the table on
the screen the scatter diagram for the
data is also shown
it can be observed from the graph that
as X increases y also increases
proportionally hence the points are
linear
in this type of correlation as the value
of the X variable increases the value of
y also increases but not in the same
proportion
to demonstrate this the following
example is presented
the increase in savings for increase in
salary is shown in the table
as you can notice in the scatter diagram
the points are not linear although the
value of y increases with increase in
the value of x the increase is not
proportional
when a change in one variable has no
impact on the other there is no relation
or correlation between them
let us consider the following example
to study the relation between the number
of fresh graduates in the city and the
job openings available data for both was
collected over a few months and
tabulated as shown
the scatter diagram for the same is also
displayed
it can be observed that the data points
are scattered and there is no Trend
emerging from the graph
therefore there is no correlation
between the number of fresh graduates
and the number of job openings in the
city
in moderate negative correlation an
increase in one variable results in a
decrease in the other variable however
this change is not proportional to the
change in the first variable
to demonstrate modern negative
correlation the prices of different
products are listed along with the
number of units sold for each product
the data is shown in the table
from the scatter diagram shown it can be
observed that higher the price of a
product lesser are the number of units
of that product sold
however the decrease in the number of
units with increasing price is not
proportional
imperfect negative correlation an
increase in one variable results in a
proportional decrease of the other
variable
this is also an example of one is to one
correlation as an example the effect of
an increase in the project time
extension on the success of project is
considered the data is shown in the
table the scattered diagram for the data
shows a proportional decrease in the
probability of the Project's success
with each extension of the project time
hence the points are linear
perfect correlations are rare in the
real world when encountered they should
be investigated and verified
in this screen we will look at another
graphical method histograms
histograms are similar to bar graphs
except that the data in histograms is
grouped into intervals they are used to
represent category wise data graphically
a histogram is best suited for
continuous data
the following example illustrates how a
histogram is used to represent data
data on the number of hours spent by a
group of 15 people on a special project
in one week is collected
this data is then divided into intervals
of two and the frequency table for the
data is created
the histogram for the same data is also
displayed
looking at the histogram it can be
observed at a glance that most of the
team members spent between two to four
hours on the project
in the following screen we will look at
the next graphical method normal
probability plots
normal probability plots are used to
identify if a sample has been taken from
a normal distributed population
when sample data from a normal
distributed population is represented as
a normal probability plot it forms a
straight line
the following example is presented to
illustrate normal probability plots
a sampling of diameters from a drilling
operation is done and the data is
recorded the data set is given to create
a normal probability plot the first step
is to construct a cumulative frequency
distribution table
this is followed by calculating the mean
rank probability by dividing the
cumulative frequency by the number of
samples plus one and multiplying the
answer by 100.
the fully populated table for mean rank
probability estimation is shown on the
screen take a look at the same
in The Next Step a graph is plotted on
log paper or with minitab using this
data minitab is a statistical software
used in Six Sigma minitab normal
probability plot instructions are also
given on the screen
the completed graph is shown on the
screen
from the graph it can be seen that the
random sample forms a straight line and
therefore the data is taken from a
normally distributed population
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in this topic we will discuss
measurement system analysis or MSA in
detail let us understand what MSA is in
the following screen throughout the
DMACC process the output of the
measurement system Ms is used for
metrics analysis and control efforts
an error-prone measurement system will
only lead to incorrect data incorrect
data leads to incorrect conclusions
it is important to set right the MS
before collecting the data
measurement system analysis or MSA is a
technique that identifies measurement
error or variation and sources of that
error in order to reduce the variation
it evaluates the measuring system to
ensure the Integrity of data used for
analysis
MSA is therefore one of the first
activities in the measure phase
the measurement system's capability is
calculated analyzed and interpreted
using gauge repeatability and
reproducibility to determine measurement
correlation bias linearity percent
agreement and precision or tolerance
let us discuss the objectives of MSA in
the next screen
a primary objective of MSA is to obtain
information about the type of
measurement variation associated with
the measurement system it is also used
to establish criteria to accept and
release new measuring equipment
MSA also Compares measuring one method
against another it helps to form a basis
for evaluating a method which is
suspected of being deficient
the measurement system variations should
be resolved to arrive at the correct
baselines for the project objectives
as baselines contain crucial data based
on which decisions are taken it is
extremely important that the measurement
system be free of error as far as
possible
let us look at measurement analysis in
detail in the next screen
in measurement analysis The observed
value is equal to the sum of the true
value and the measurement error the
measurement error can be a negative or a
positive value
measurement error refers to the net
effect of all sources of measurement
variability that cause and observed
value to deviate from the True Value
true variability is the sum of the
process variability and the measurement
variability
process variability and measurement
variability must be evaluated and
improved together
measurement variability should be
addressed before looking at process
variability
if process variability is corrected
before resolving measurement variability
then any improvements to the process
cannot be trusted to have taken place
owing to a faulty measurement system
in the following screen we will identify
the types of measurement errors
the two types of measurement errors are
measurement system bias and measurement
system variation
click each type to know more
measurement system bias involves
calibration study in the calibration
study the total mean is given by the sum
of the process mean and the measurement
mean the statistical notation is shown
on the screen
measurement system variation involves
gauge repeatability and reproducibility
or grr study in the grr study the total
variance is calculated by adding the
process variance with the measurement
variation
the statistical notation is shown on the
screen
in this screen we will discuss the
sources of variation the chart on the
screen lists the different sources of
variation observe process variation is
divided into two actual process
variation and measurement variation
actual process variation can be divided
into long-term and short-term process
variations
in a gauge RR study process variation is
often called heart variation
measurement variation can be divided
into variations caused by operators and
variations due to the gauge
the variation due to operators is owing
to reproducibility
variation due to gauges owing to
repeatability both actual process
variation and measurement variation have
a common factor that is variation within
a sample
let us understand gauge repeatability
and reproducibility or grr in the next
screen
gauge repeatability and reproducibility
or grr is a statistical technique to
assess if a gauge or gauging system will
obtain the same reading each time a
particular characteristic or parameter
is measured gauge repeatability is the
variation in measurement when one
operator uses the same gauge to measure
identical characteristics of the same
part repeatedly gauge reproducibility is
the variation in the average of
measurements when different operators
use the same gauge to measure identical
characteristics of the same part
the figures on the screen illustrate
gauge repeatability and reproducibility
in the next screen we will discuss the
components of grr study
the figure on the screen illustrates the
difference between gauge repeatability
and reproducibility the figure shows the
repeatability and reproducibility for
six different parts represented by the
numbers one to six for two different
trial readings by three different
operators
as can be observed a difference in
reading for part one indicated by the
color green by three different operators
is known as reproducibility error a
difference in reading of part 4
indicated by Red by the same operator in
two different trials is known as the
repeatability error in the following
screen we will look at some guidelines
for gauge repeatability and
reproducibility studies
the following should be kept in mind
while carrying out gauge repeatability
and reproducibility or grr studies
grr studies should be performed over the
range of expected observations
care should be taken to use actual
equipment for grr studies written
procedures and approved practices should
be followed as would have been in actual
operations
the measurement variability should be
represented as is not the way it was
designed to be
after grr the measurement variability is
separated into casual components sorted
according to priority and then targeted
for action
in the following screen let us look at
some more Concepts associated with grr
bias is the distance between the sample
mean value and the sample True Value it
is also called accuracy
bias is equal to mean minus reference
value process variation is equal to six
times the standard deviation
the bias percentage is calculated as
bias divided by the process variation
the next term is linearity linearity
refers to the consistency of bias over
the range of the gauge
linearity is given by the product of
slope and process variation
Precision is the degree of repeatability
or closeness of data
smaller the dispersion in the data set
better the Precision
the variation in the gauge is the sum of
variation due to repeatability and the
variation due to reproducibility
in the following screen we will
understand measurement resolution
measurement resolution is the smallest
detectable increment that an instrument
will measure or display the number of
increments in the measurement system
should extend over the full range for a
given parameter
some examples of wrong gauges or
incorrect measurement resolution are
given here
a truck weighing scale is used for
measuring the weight of a t-pack
a caliper capable of measuring
differences of 0.1 millimeters is used
to show compliance when the tolerance
limits are plus or minus 0.07
millimeters
thus the measurement system that matches
the range of the data should only be
used
an important prerequisite for GR studies
is that the gauge has an acceptable
resolution
in the next screen we will look at
examples for repeatability and
reproducibility
repeatability is also called equipment
variation or EV it occurs when the same
technician or operator repeatedly
measures the same part or process under
identical conditions with the same
measurement system
the following example illustrates this
concept
a 36 kilometer per hour Pace mechanism
is timed by a single operator over a
distance of 100 meters on a stopwatch
and three readings are taken
trial one takes nine seconds trial two
takes 10 seconds and trial 3 takes 11
seconds
the process is measured with the same
equipment in identical conditions by the
same operator assuming no operator error
the variation in the three readings is
known as repeatability or equipment
variation
reproducibility is also called appraiser
variation or AV it occurs when different
technicians or operators measure the
same part or process under identical
conditions using the same measurement
system
let us extend the example for
repeatability to include data measured
by two operators
the readings are displayed on the slide
the difference in the readings of both
operators is called reproducibility or
appraiser variation
it is important to resolve equipment
variation before appraiser variation if
appraiser variation is resolved first
the results will still not be identical
due to variation in the equipment itself
in this screen we will learn about data
collection in grr there are some
important considerations for data
collection in grr studies there are
usually three operators and around 10
units to measure General sampling
techniques must be used to represent the
population and each unit must be
measured two to three times by each
operator
it is important that the gauge be
calibrated accurately it should also be
ensured that the gauge has an acceptable
resolution
another practice is that the first
operator measures all the units in
random order then this order is
maintained by all other operators all
the trials must be repeated
in the next screen we will discuss the
Anova method of analyzing grr studies
the Anova method is considered to be the
best method for analyzing grr studies
this is because of two reasons the first
being Anova not only separates equipment
and operator variation but also provides
Insight on the combined effect of the
two second Anova uses standard deviation
instead of range as a measure of
variation and therefore gives a better
estimate of the measurement system
variation
the one drawback of using Anova is the
considerations of time resources and
cost
in the next screen we will understand
how MSA can be interpreted
two results are possible for an MSA
in the first case the reproducibility
error is larger than the repeatability
error this occurs when the operators are
not trained and calibrations on the
gauge dial are not clear
the other possibility is that the
repeatability error is larger than the
reproducibility error this is clearly a
maintenance issue and can be resolved by
calibrating the equipment or performing
maintenance on the equipment
this indicates that the gauge needs
redesigned to be more rigid and the
location needs to be improved it also
occurs when there is ambiguity in Sops
MSA is an experiment which seeks to
identify the components of variation in
the measurement in the following screen
we will look at a template used for grr
studies
a sample gauge RR sheet is given on this
screen The Operators here are Andrew
Murphy and Lucy Wang who are the
appraisers in this study
they have measured and raided the
performance of three employees Ibraham
glassoff Brianna Scott and Jason Schmidt
this is a sample template for a gauge
RNR study
the parts are shown across the top of
the sheet in this case the measurement
system is being evaluated using three
parts the employees Abraham glassoff
Rhianna Scott and Jason Schmidt The
Operators measure each part repeatedly
from this data the average X and ranges
are for each inspector and for each part
are calculated
the grand average for each inspector and
each part is also calculated
in this example a control limit UCL in
the sheet was compared with the
difference in averages of the two
inspectors to identify if there is a
significant difference in their
measurements their difference is
0.111 which is outside the UCL of
0.108 given the r average of 0.042
in the next screen we will look at the
results page for this grr study
the sheet on the screen displays the
results for the data entered in the
template in the previous screen please
spend some time to go through the data
for a better understanding of the
concept
in the following screen we will look at
the interpretation to this results page
the percentage grr value is highlighted
in the center right of the table in the
previous screen
there are three important observations
to be made here about the gauge RR study
first this study also shows the
interaction between operators and parts
If the percentage grr value is less than
30 then the gauge is acceptable and the
measurement system does not require any
change if the value is greater than 30
then the gauge needs correction
the equipment variation is checked and
resolved first followed by the appraiser
variation
second if EV equals zero it means the MS
is reliable the equipment is perfect and
the variation in the gauge is
contributed by different operators
if the AV is equal to zero the MS is
precise
third if e v is equal to zero and there
is a v The Operators have to be trained
to ensure all operators follow identical
steps during measurement and the AV is
minimal
the interaction between operators and
parts can also be studied under grr
using part variation the trueness and
precision cannot be determined in a grr
if only one gauge or measurement method
is evaluated as it may have an inherent
bias that would go undetected merely by
varying operators and parts
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will discuss process
and performance capability in detail
in the following screen we will look at
the differences between natural process
limits and specification limits
natural process limits or control limits
are derived from the process data and
are the voice of the process
the data consists of real-time values
from past process performance therefore
these values represent the actual
process limits and indicate variation in
the process
the two control limits are upper control
limit UCL and lower control limit LCL
specification limits are provided by
customers based on their requirements or
the voice of the customer and cannot be
changed by the organization these limits
act as targets for the organization and
processes are designed around the
requirements
the product or service has to meet
customer requirements and has to be well
within the specification limits
If the product or service does not meet
customer requirements it is considered
as a defect
therefore specification limits are the
intended results or requirements from
the product or service that are defined
by the customer
the two specification limits are upper
specification limit or USL and lower
specification limit or LSL
the difference between the two is called
tolerance
an important point to note is that for a
process if the control limits lie within
the specification limits the process is
said to be under control
conversely if specification limits lie
within the control limits the process
will not meet customer requirements
in the following screen we will look at
process performance metrics and how they
are calculated
the two major metrics used to measure
process performance are defects per unit
or dpu and defects per million
opportunities or dpmo
dpu is calculated by dividing the number
of defects by the total number of units
dpmo is calculated by multiplying the
defects per opportunity with 1 million
in the following screen we will look at
an example for calculating process
performance
in this example the quality control
Department checks the quality of
finished goods by sampling a batch of 10
items from the produced lot every hour
the data is collected over 24 hours the
table displays the data for the number
of defectives for the sampling period
if items are consistently found to be
outside the control limits on any given
day the production process is stopped
for the next day
let us now interpret the results of the
sampling in this example as the sample
size is constant dpu or P bar is used to
calculate the process capability
the total number of defectives is 34 and
the subgroup size is 10. the total
number of units is 10 multiplied by 24
which is 240. the defects per unit is
0.0124
the defects per million opportunities is
obtained by multiplying the defects per
unit with 1 million which is 141 666.66
therefore by looking at the dpmo table
it can be said that the process is
currently working at 2.6 Sigma or 86.4
percent yield
we will learn about process stability
studies in this screen
the activities carried out in the
measure phase are MSA collection of data
statistical calculations and checking
for accuracy and validity this is
followed by a test for stability as
changes cannot be made to an unstable
process with a set of data believed to
be accurate the process is checked for
stability this is important because if a
process is unstable no changes can be
implemented
why does a process become unstable
a process can become unstable due to
special causes of variation multiple
special causes of variation lead to
instability
a single special cause leads to an out
of control condition
run charts in minitab can be used to
check for process stability let us look
at the steps to plot a run chart in
minitab in the following screen
to plot a run chart in minitab first
enter the sample data collected to check
for stability
next click stat on the minitab window
followed by quality tools next click run
charts select the column and choose the
subgroup size as two click ok
the graph shown on the screen is
interpreted by looking at the last four
values if any of the P values is less
than 0.05 the presence of special causes
of variation can be validated
this means there is a good chance that
the process will become unstable
in the following screen we will look at
process stability studies causes of
variation
variation can be due to two types of
causes common causes of variation and
special causes of variation
click each type to learn more
common causes of variation are the many
sources of variation within a process
which have a stable and repeatable
distribution over a period they
contribute to a state of statistical
control where the output is predictable
some other factors which do not always
act on the process can also cause
variation these are special causes of
variation these are external to the
process and are irregular in nature when
present the process distribution changes
and the process output is not stable
over a period special causes may result
in defects and need to be eliminated to
bring the process under control
run charts indicate the presence of
special causes of variation in the
process
if special causes are detected the
process has to be brought to a stop and
a root cause analysis has to be carried
out if the root cause analysis reveals
the special cause to be undesirable
corrective actions are taken to remove
the special cause
we will learn about verifying process
stability and normality in this screen
based on the type of variation of
process exhibits it can be verified if
the process is in control
if there are special causes of variation
the process output is not stable over
time
the process cannot be said to be in
control
conversely if there are only common
causes of variation in a process the
output forms a distribution that is
stable and predictable over time a
process being in control means the
process does not have any special causes
of variation
once a process is understood to be
stable the control chart data can be
used to calculate the process capability
indices
in the following screen we will discuss
process capability studies process
capability is the actual variation in
the process specification to carry out a
process capability study first plan for
data collection next collect the data
finally plot and analyze the results
obtaining the appropriate sampling plan
for the process capability study depends
on the purpose and whether there are any
customer or standard requirements for
the study
for new processes or a project proposal
the project capability can be estimated
by a pilot run let us look at the
objectives of process capability studies
in the next screen the objectives of a
process capability study are to
establish a state of control over a
manufacturing process and then maintain
the state of control over a period of
time
on comparing the natural process limits
or the control limits within the
specification limits any of the
following outcomes is possible
first the process limits are found to
fall between the specification limits
this shows the process is running well
and no action is required the second
possibility is that the process spread
and the specification spread are
approximately the same in this case the
process is centered by making an
adjustment to the centering of the
process
this would bring the batch of products
within the specifications
the third possibility is that the
process limits fall outside the
specification limits in this case reduce
the variability by partitioning the
pieces of batches to locate and Target
the largest Defender
a design experiment can be used to
identify the primary source of variation
in the following screen we will learn
about identifying characteristics in
process capability
process capability deals with the
ability of the process to meet customer
requirements therefore it is crucial
that the characteristics selected for a
process capability study indicates a key
factor in the quantity of the product or
process also it should be possible to
influence the value of the
characteristic by adjusting the process
the operating conditions that affect the
characteristic should also be defined
and controlled apart from these
requirements other factors determining
the characteristics to be measured are
customer purchase order requirements or
industry standards
in the following screen we will look at
identifying specifications or tolerances
in process capability
the process specification or tolerances
are defined either by industry standards
based on customer requirements or by the
organization's engineering department in
consultation with the customer
a stability study followed by a
comprehensive capability study also
helps in identifying if the process mean
meets the Target or the customer mean
the process capability study indicates
whether the process is capable it is
used to determine if the output
consistently meets specifications and
the probability of a defect or defective
this information is used to evaluate and
improve the process to meet the
tolerance requirements in the following
screen we will learn about process
performance indices
process performance is defined as a
statistical measurement of the outcome
of a process characteristic which may or
may not have been demonstrated to be in
a state of statistical control
in other words it is an estimate of the
process capability of a process during
its initial setup before it has been
brought into a state of statistical
control it differs from the process
capability in that for process
performance a state of statistical
control is not required the three basic
process performance indices are process
performance or PP process performance
index or PPK and process capability
index denoted as PPM or CPM
click each index to know more
PP stands for process performance it is
computed by subtracting the lower
specification limit from the upper
specification limit the whole divided by
natural process variation or Six Sigma
PPK is the process performance index and
a minimum of the values of the upper and
lower process capability indices the
upper and lower process capability
indices are calculated as shown on the
screen PPU or upper process capability
index is given by the formula USL minus
x divided by 3s
PPL or lower process capability index is
given by x minus LSL divided by 3s here
x is process average better known as X
bar and S is sample standard deviation
CPM denotes the process capability index
mean which accounts for the location of
the process average relative to a Target
value it can be calculated as shown on
the screen here myu stands for process
average Sigma symbol denotes the process
standard deviation USL is the upper
specification limit and LSL is the lower
specification limit
T is the target value which is typically
the center of the tolerance x i is the
sample reading and N is the number of
sample ratings
we will look at the key terms in process
capability in this screen
zst or short-term capability is the
potential performance of the process in
control at any given point of time it is
based on the sample collected in the
short term
the long-term performance is denoted by
zlt it is the actual performance of the
process over a given period of time
subgroups are several small samples
collected consecutively each sample
forms a subgroup the subgroups are
chosen so that the data points are
likely to be identical within the
subgroup but different between two
subgroups
the process shift is calculated by
subtracting the long-term capability
from the short-term capability
the process shift also reflects how well
a process is controlled it is usually a
factor of 1.5
let us look at short-term and long-term
process capability in the next screen
the concept of short-term and long-term
process shift is explained graphically
on this screen there are three different
samples taken at Time 1 time 2 and time
3. the smaller waveforms represent the
short-term capability and they are
joined with their means to show the
shift in long-term performance the
long-term performance curve is shown
below with the target value marked in
the center it is important to note that
over a period of time or subgroups a
typical process will shift by
approximately 1.5 times the standard
deviation
also long-term variation is more than
short-term variation this difference is
known as the sigma shift and is an
indicator of the process control
the reasons for a process shift include
changes in operators raw material used
wear and tear and time periods
we will discuss the assumptions and
conventions of process variations in the
following screen
long-term variation is always longer
than short-term variation click each
term to know more
short-term variations are due to the
common causes the variance is inherent
in the process and known as the natural
variation
short-term variations show variation
within subgroup and are therefore called
within subgroup variation
they are usually a small number of
samples collected at Short intervals in
short-term variation the variation due
to common causes are captured however
common causes are difficult to identify
and correct the process may have to be
redesigned to remove common causes of
variation
long-term variations are due to common
as well as special causes the added
variation or abnormal variation is due
to factors external to the usual process
long-term variation is also known as the
overall variation and is a sample
standard deviation for all the samples
put together
long-term variation shows variations
within the subgroup and between
subgroups the special causes increasing
variation include changes in operators
raw material and wear and tear the
special causes need to be identified and
corrected for process Improvement
this screen explains how the factors of
stability capability spread and defect
summary are used to interpret the
process condition this table gives the
process condition for different levels
or types of variation with reference to
common causes and special causes
the table is read as follows
in the first scenario the process has
lesser common causes of variation for
CCV and note special causes of variation
or SCV in this case the variability is
less the capability is high the
possibility of defects is less and the
process is said to be capable and in
control
next if the process has lesser CCV and
some SCV are present then it has high
variability low capability and a high
possibility of defects the process is
said to be out of control and incapable
the third possibility is that the
process has high CCV and no SCV in this
case the variability is moderate to high
the capability is very low and
possibility of defects is very high
although the process is in control it is
incapable
finally at the Other Extreme is the
situation where the process has high CCV
and SCV is also present here the process
has high variability low capability high
possibility of defects and is out of
control and incapable
this table is a quick reference to
understand process conditions
in the next screen we will compare the
CPK and CP values
when CPK and CP values are compared
three outcomes are possible when CPK is
lesser than CP it can be inferred that
the mean is not centered when CPK is
equal to CV the inference is that the
process is accurate the process is
considered capable if CPK is greater
than one this will happen only if
variations are in control
CPK can never be greater than CP if this
situation occurs the calculations have
to be rechecked we will look at an
example problem for calculating process
variation in the following screen
the table on this screen shows data for
customer complaint resolution time over
a period of three weeks each week's data
forms a subgroup for example the
resolution time is 48 hours for a
particular case in week one in week two
the case takes up 50 hours and in week 3
it takes about 49 hours
the subgroup size is 10. let us
understand how to calculate long-term
and short-term standard deviations are
calculated for this data
the average for each week is calculated
by dividing the total number of
complaints resolved by the subgroup size
a grand average is also calculated for
all the three weeks the variations
within subgroups and between subgroups
for each week are calculated this is
followed by calculating the total
variations within and between subgroups
overall variation is given by the sum of
total variation within subgroups and
total variation between subgroups
finally the standard deviations for the
short term and the long term are
calculated using the formula given on
the screen
the results for the process variation
calculations are as follows
the grand average for all three weeks is
47.5
the total variation within subgroups is
1023.8
the total variation between subgroups is
161.67
both these variations are added to give
the overall variation of 1185.5
the short-term standard deviation is 6.2
and the long-term standard deviation is
6.4
note that the overall variation can also
be calculated with the usual sample
variance formula
let us discuss the effect of mean shift
on the process capability in this grain
the table given here shows that effect
level at different Sigma multiple values
and different mean shifts from the table
it can be seen that when the mean is
centered within the specification limits
and the process capability is one that
is plus or minus 3s fits within the
specification limits the dpmo is 2700
percent and the probability of a good
result is 99.73 percent if the mean
shifts by 1.5 Sigma then a tail moves
outside the specification limit to a
greater extent now the dpmo increases to
over 66 000. this is almost a twenty
five hundred percent increase in defects
if the process has a process capability
of two that is plus or minus 6s fits
within the specification limits and the
mean shifts by 1.5 Sigma then the
probability of a good result is
99.9966 percent
this is the same as a process with a
capability of 1.5 that is plus or minus
4.5 s fitting within the specification
limits and no shift in the mean
the long-term and short-term capability
table shows the variations in
capabilities
for the purposes of Six Sigma the
assumption is that the long-term
variability will have a 1.5 s difference
from the short-term variability
as seen in statistical process control
this assumption can be challenged if
control charts are used and these kinds
of shifts are detected quickly
in the chart it can be seen that the
mean shift is negligible as the process
capability increases therefore for a Six
Sigma process the long-term variation
does not have much effect in the next
screen we will look at Key Concepts in
process capability for attribute data
the customary procedure for defining
process capability for attribute data is
to define the mean rate of
non-conformity defects and defectives
are examples of non-conformity
defects per million opportunities or
dpmo is the measure of process
capability for attribute data for this
the mean and the standard deviation for
attribute data have to be defined for
defectives p bar is used for checking
process capability for both constant and
variable sample sizes for defects c bar
and u-bar are used for constant and
variable sample sizes respectively
the P Bar C bar and u-bar are of the
equivalent of the standard deviation
denoted by Sigma for continuous data in
this topic we will learn about the
patterns of variation in detail let us
start with the classes of distributions
in the following screen
when data obtained from the measurement
phase is plotted on a chart it is
observed that it exhibits a variety of
distributions depending on the data type
and its source these distribution
patterns will help you understand the
data better
probability statistics and inferential
statistics are the methods used to
describe the parameters for the classes
of distributions
click each method to know more
probability is based on the assumed
model of distribution and it is used to
find the chances of a certain outcome or
event to occur
statistics uses the measured data to
determine a model to describe the data
used
inferential statistics describe the
population parameters based on the
sample data using a particular model
in this screen we will discuss the types
of distributions there are two types of
distributions
discrete distribution and continuous
distribution
discrete distribution includes binomial
distribution and poisson distribution
continuous distribution includes normal
distribution chi-square distribution T
distribution and F distribution let us
learn about discrete probability
distribution in the following screen
discrete probability distribution is
characterized by the probability Mass
function it is important to be familiar
with discrete distributions while
dealing with discrete data some of the
examples of discrete probability
distribution are binomial distribution
poisson distribution negative binomial
distribution geometric distribution and
Hyper geometric distribution we will
focus only on the two most useful
discrete distributions binomial
distribution and poisson distribution
like most probability distributions
these distributions also help in
predicting the sample behavior that has
been observed in a population
let us learn about binomial distribution
in the following screen
binomial distribution is a probability
distribution for discrete data named
after the Swiss mathematician Jacob
Bernoulli it is an application of
popular knowledge to predict the sample
Behavior
binomial distribution also describes the
discrete data as a result of a
particular process like the tossing of a
coin for a fixed number of times and the
success or failure in an interview
a process is known as Bernoulli's
process when the process output has only
two possible values like defective or OK
pass or fail and yes or no binomial
distribution is used to deal with
defective items defect is any
non-compliance with a specification
defective is a product or service with
at least one defect
binomial distribution is most suitable
when the sample size is less than 30 and
less than 10 percent of the population
it is the percentage of non-defective
items provided the probability of
creating a defective item Remains the
Same over a period
let us look at the equation
the probability of exactly our successes
out of a sample size of n is denoted by
P of R which is equal to NCR whole
multiplied by P to the power of R and 1
minus P whole to the power of n minus r
in the equation B is the probability of
success R is the number of successes
desired and N is the sample size
to continue discussing the binomial
distribution let us look at some of its
key calculations in the following screen
the mean of a binomial distribution is
denoted by Mio and is given by n
multiplied by P the standard deviation
of a binomial distribution is denoted by
Sigma which is equal to n multiplied by
P multiplied by 1 minus p
the method of calculating factorials say
a factorial of 5 is the product of five
four three two and one which is equal to
120.
similarly factorial of 4 is the product
of four three two and one which is equal
to 24.
let us look at an example of calculating
binomial distribution in the next screen
suppose you wish to know the probability
of getting heads five times in eight
coin tosses you can use the binomial
equation for the same
click the answer button to see how this
is done
the tossing of a coin has only two
outcomes heads and tails it means that
the probability of each outcome is 0.5
and it remains fixed over a period of
time Additionally the outcomes are
statistically independent
in this case the probability of success
denoted by P is 0.5 the number of
successes desired is denoted by R which
is 5 and the sample size is denoted by n
which is 8. therefore the probability of
five heads is equal to factorial of 8 CR
which is eight divided by a factorial of
5 and factorial of eight minus five
whole multiplied by 0.5 to the power of
5 multiplied by one minus 0.5 whole to
the power of eight minus five
this calculation gives a result of
0.2187 which is equal to
21.87 percent
let us learn about croissant
distribution in this screen
full song distribution is named after
Simeon Denis poisson and is also used
for discrete data
poisson distribution is an application
of the population knowledge to predict
the sample Behavior it is generally used
for describing the probability
distribution of an event with respect to
time or space
some of the characteristics of poisson
distribution are as follows
poisson distribution describes the
discrete data resulting from a process
like the number of calls received by a
call center agent or the number of
accidents at a signal
unlike binomial distribution which deals
with binary discrete data poisson
distribution deals with integers which
can take any value poisson distribution
is suitable for analyzing situations
wherein the number of Trials similar to
the sample size in binomial distribution
is large and tends towards Infinity
additionally it is used in situations
where the probability of success in each
trial is very small almost tending
towards zero this is the reason why
poisson distribution is applicable for
predicting the occurrence of rare events
like plane crashes car accidents Etc and
is therefore widely used in the
insurance sector poisson distribution
can be used for predicting the number of
defects as well given a low defect
occurrence rate
let us look at the formula for
calculating poisson distribution in the
next screen the poisson distribution for
a probability of exactly X occurrences
is given by P of x equals to Lambda to
the power of X multiplied with log e to
the power of minus Lambda whole divided
by factorial of X in this equation
Lambda is the mean number of occurrences
during the interval X is the number of
occurrences desired and E is the base of
natural logarithm which is equal to
2.71828
the mean of the poisson distribution is
given by the Lambda and the standard
deviation of a poisson distribution is
given by Sigma which is the square root
of Lambda
let us look at an example to calculate
poisson distribution in the next screen
the past records of a row Junction which
is accident prone show a mean number of
five accidents per week at this Junction
assume that the number of accidents
follows up poisson distribution and
calculate the probability of any number
of accidents happening in a week click
the button to know the answer
given the situation you know that the
value of Lambda or mean is 5. so P of 0
that is the probability of zero
accidents per week is calculated as 5 to
the power of zero multiplied by e to the
power of minus five whole divided by a
factorial of zero the answer is 0.006
applying the same formula the
probability of one accident per week is
0.03 the probability of more than two
accidents per week is one minus the sum
of probabilities of zero one and two
accidents which is
0.884 in other words the probability is
88.4 percent
let us learn about continuous
probability distribution in this screen
continuous probability distribution is
characterized by the probability density
function
a variable is said to be continuous if
the range of possible values Falls along
a continuum
for example loudness of cheering at a
ball game weight of cookies in a package
length of a pen or the time required to
assemble a car
continuous probability distributions
help in predicting the sample Behavior
observed in a population
let us learn about normal distribution
in this screen the normal or gaussian
distribution is a continuous probability
distribution
the normal distribution is represented
as n and depends on two factors Miu
which stands for mean and sigma which
gives the standard deviation of the data
points normal distribution normally has
a higher frequency of values around the
mean and lesser occurrences away from it
it is often used as a first
approximation to describe real valued
random variables that tend to Cluster
around a single mean value
the distribution is bell-shaped and
symmetrical the total area under the
normal curve is one which is p of x
various types of data such as body
weight height the output of a
manufacturing device Etc follow the
normal distribution additionally normal
distribution is continuous and
symmetrical with the tails asymptotic to
the x-axis which means they touch the
x-axis at Infinity let us continue to
discuss normal distribution in the
following screen
in a normal distribution to standardize
comparisons of dispersion or the
different measurement units like inches
meters grams Etc a standard Z variable
is used the uses of Z value are as
follows while the value of Z or the
number of standard deviations is unique
for each probability within the normal
distribution it helps in finding
probabilities of data points anywhere
within the distribution
it is dimensionless as well that is it
has no units such as millimeters liters
coulombs Etc
there are different formulas to arrive
at the normal distribution we will focus
on one commonly used formula for
calculating normal distribution which is
z equals y minus mu whole divided by
Sigma here Z is the number of standard
deviations between Y and the mean
denoted by mu Y is the value of the data
point in concern mu is mean of the
population or data points and sigma is
the standard deviation of the population
or data points let us look at an example
for calculating normal distribution in
the following screen
suppose the time taken to resolve
customer problems follows a normal
distribution with a mean of 250 hours
and standard deviation of 23 hours find
the probability of a problem resolution
taking more than 300 hours click the
button to know the answer
in this case Y is equal to 300 mu equals
250 and sigma equals 23. applying the
normal distribution formula Z is equal
to 300 minus 250 whole divided by 23.
the result is 2.17 when you look at the
normal distribution table the Z value of
2.17 covers an area of
0.98499 under itself
this means the probability of a problem
taking 0 to 300 hours to be resolved is
98.5 percent and therefore the chances
of a problem resolution taking more than
300 hours is 1.5 percent
let us understand the usage of Z table
in this screen
the graphical representation of Z table
usage is given here
the probability of areas under the curve
is one
for the actual value one can identify
the z-score by using the Z table
as shown this probability is the area
under the curve to the left of point
plus a to zero
using the actual data when you calculate
mean and standard deviation and the
values are 25 and 5 respectively it is
the normal distribution
if the same data is standardized to a
mean value of zero and standard
deviation value of one it is the
standard normal distribution
in the next screen we will take a look
at the Z table
the Z table gives the probability that Z
is between 0 and a positive number there
are different forms of normal
distribution Z tables followed globally
the most common form of Z table with
positive Z scores is shown here
the value of a called the percentage
point is given along the borders of the
table in bold and is to two decimal
places
the values in the main table are the
probabilities that Z is between 0 and
plus a
note that the values running down the
table are to one decimal place
the numbers along the column change only
for the second decimal place
let us look at some examples on how to
use a z table in the following screen
let us find the value of P of Z Less
Than Zero
the table is not needed to find the
answer once we know that the variable Z
takes a value less than or equal to zero
first the area under the curve is one
and second the curve is symmetrical
about Z equals zero hence there is 0.5
or 50 percent above chance of Z equals 0
and 0.5 or 50 percent below chance of Z
equals zero
let us find the value of P of Z greater
than 1.12
in this case the chance of Z is greater
than a number in this case 1.12
you can find this by using the following
fact
the opposite or complement of an event
of a is the event of not a that is the
opposite or complement of event a
occurring is the event a not occurring
its probability is given by P of not a
equals 1 minus P of a
in other words P of Z greater than 1.12
is 1 minus the opposite which is p of Z
lesser than 1.12
using the table P of Z less than 1.12
equals 0.5 plus P of 0 less than Z less
than 1.12 equals 0.5 plus
0.3686 which is
0.8686 hence the answer is p of Z
greater than 1.12 equals 1 minus
0.8686 which is
0.1314 note the answer is less than 0.5
let us find the value of P of Z lies
between 0 and 1.12
in this case where Z Falls within an
interval the probability can be read
straight off the table
P of Z lies between 0 and 1.12 equals
0.3686
we will learn about chi-square
distribution in this screen
chi-square distribution is also known as
Chi Squared or chi-square distribution
Chi Squared with K of 1 degrees of
freedom is the distribution of a sum of
the squares of K independent standard
normal random variables
the chi-square distribution is one of
the most widely used probability
distributions in inferential statistics
it is also known as hypothesis testing
and the distribution is used in
hypothesis tests
when used in hypothesis tests it only
needs one sample for the test to be
conducted
conventionally degree of freedom is k1
where K is the sample size
click the button to view the chi-squared
distribution formula
chi-square calculated or Sigma or the
chi-square index equals F of O minus F
of e the whole squared divided by F of e
here F of O stands for an observed
frequency and F of e stands for an
expected frequency determined through a
contingency table
we will learn about the chi-square
distribution in detail in the later part
of this lesson let us proceed to the
next screen to discuss T distribution
the T distribution method is the most
appropriate method to be used in the
following situations
when you have a sample size of less than
30 when the population standard
deviation is not known when the
population is approximately normal
unlike the normal distribution a t
distribution is lower at the mean and
higher at the Tails as seen in the image
T distribution is used for hypothesis
testing
also as seen in the image the T
distribution is symmetrical in shape but
flatter than the normal distribution
as the sample size increases the
t-distribution approaches normality
for every possible sample size or
degrees of freedom there is a different
T distribution
let us learn about F distribution in the
following screen
the F distribution is a ratio of two
chi-squared distributions
a specific F distribution is denoted by
the ratio of the degrees of freedom for
the numerator chi-square and the degrees
of freedom for the denominator
chi-square
the f-test is performed to calculate and
observe if the standard deviations or
variances of two processes are
significantly different
the project teams are usually concerned
about reducing the process variance as
per the formula f calculated equals S1
Square divided by S2 Square where S1 and
S2 are the standard deviations of the
two samples
if the F calculated is one it implies
there is no difference in the variance
if S1 is greater than S2 then the
numerator must be greater than the
denominator in other words df1 equals N1
minus 1 and df2 equals N2 minus 1.
from the F distribution table you can
easily find out the critical F
distribution at Alpha and the degrees of
freedom of the samples of two different
processes df1 and df2
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will discuss
exploratory data analysis in detail let
us learn about multivariate studies in
the following screen
multi-vari studies or multi-variable
studies are used to analyze variation in
a process
analyzing variation helps in
investigating the stability of a process
more stable the process less is the
variation
multivari studies also help in
identifying areas to be investigated
finally they help in breaking down the
variation into components to make the
required improvements
multivariate studies classify variation
sources into three major types
positional cyclical and temporal
click each type to learn more
positional variation occurs within a
single piece or a product variation in
pieces of a batch is also an example of
positional variation in positional
variation measurements at different
locations of a piece would produce
different values
suppose a company is manufacturing a
metal plate of thickness one inch and
the plate thickness is different at many
points it is an example of positional
variation
some of the other examples can be pallet
stacking in a truck temperature gradient
in an oven variation observed from
cavity to cavity within a mold region of
a country and line on invoice
cyclical variation occurs when
measurement differs from piece to piece
or product to product but over a short
period of time
time is important because certain
measurements may change if a product
such as a hot metal sheet is measured
after a long interval if the measurement
at the same location in a piece varies
with different pieces it is an example
of cyclical variation
other examples of cyclical variations
are batch to batch variation lot to lot
variation and account activity week to
week
temporal variation occurs over a longer
period of time such as machine wear and
tear and changes in efficiency of an
operator before and after lunch
temporal variations may also be seasonal
if the range of positional variation in
a piece is more in Winter than in summer
it is an example of temporal variation
the variation may occur because of
unfavorable working conditions in winter
process drift performance before and
after breaks seasonal and shift base
differences month-to-month closings and
quarterly returns can be examples of
temporal variation
we will learn about creating a multivari
chart in this screen
the outcome of multivari studies is the
multivari chart
it depicts the type of variation in the
product and helps in identifying the
root cause
there are five major steps involved in
creating a multivariate chart they are
select process and characteristics
decide sample size
create a tabulation sheet
plot the chart and Link The observed
values
click each step to learn more
the first step is to select the process
and the relevant characteristics to be
investigated
for example selecting the process where
the plate of one inch thickness is being
manufactured
in this process four equipment numbered
one to four produce the one inch plates
the characteristic to be measured is the
thickness of the plate ranging from 0.95
inch to 1.05 inches
any plate thickness outside this range
is a defect
the second step is to decide the sample
size and the frequency of data
collection
in this example the sample size is five
pieces per equivalent and the frequency
of collecting data is every two hours
starting from eight in the morning to
two in the afternoon
then the tabulation sheet is created
where the data will be recorded So one
should measure the thickness of the
plate being produced by the four
equipment and a data collection
frequency of two hours
the third step is to create a tabulation
sheet in this example the tabulation
sheet with data records containing this
screen
the path to create a multivari chart in
minitab is by selecting stat then
quality tools followed by multivari
chart
the multivari chart created from the
data recorded is shown here
the upper specification limit of 1.05
inches and the lower specification limit
of 0.95 inches has been marked by Green
lines
data outside these lines are defects
the blue dots show the positional
variation
the dots are the measurements of pieces
in a batch of any single equipped in a
batch of any single equipment
the black lines join the mean of the
data recorded from the equipment
the mean of the data recorded from the
products of equipment number three is
much below the similar mean of other
equipment
this shows that equipment number three
is producing more defects than the other
equipment
the red line is the mean of the data
recorded at a particular time
the red line Rises toward the right
which means the data points shift up
after 12 pm
this may be because of the change in
operator efficiency after a lunch break
at 12 pm
multivariate chart helps us visually
depict the variations and establish the
root causes of variations
in the next screen we will learn about
simple linear correlation
correlation means association between
variables
simple linear regression and multiple
regression techniques are very important
as they help invalidating the
association of X with y
the coefficient correlation shows the
strength of the relationship between Y
and X
to associate y with a single X and
statistically validate the relationship
correlation is used in Excel use equals
Corel Open Bracket close bracket
function to calculate correlation
coefficient
the dependent variable y may depend on
many independent variables X
but correlation is used to find the
behavior of Y as one of the X's changes
correlation helps us to predict the
direction of movement and values in y
when X changes
statistical significance of this
movement is denoted by correlation
coefficient R it is also known as
Pearson's coefficient of correlation in
any correlation the value of the
correlation coefficient is always
between
-1 and plus one
positive value of R denotes the
direction of movement in both variables
is the same
as X increases y also increases and vice
versa negative value of R denotes that
the direction of movement in both
variables is in inverse fashion
as X increases y decreases and as X
decreases y increases
when the value of R is zero it means
that there is no correlation between the
two variables
higher the absolute value of R stronger
the correlation between Y and X
absolute value of a number is its value
without the sign
plus 4 has an absolute value of 4 and -4
again has an absolute value of 4.
an R value of greater than plus 0.85 or
lesser than minus 0.85 indicates a
strong correlation hence r value of
minus 0.95 shows a stronger correlation
than the R value of minus 0.74
the next screen will elaborate on
correlation with the help of an example
and illustrations through Scatter Plots
the four graphs on the screen are
Scatter Plots displaying four different
levels of correlation
correlation measures the linear
association between the dependent
variable or output variable Y and one
independent or input variable X
as can be deduced from the graphs a
definite pattern emerges as the absolute
value of correlation coefficient R
increases
it is easy to see a pattern in r value
of 0.9 and above than to see a pattern
in r value of 0.07
it is difficult to find a pattern below
correlation coefficient of 0.5 click the
example button to know more
to understand how correlation helps let
us consider an example a correlation
test was performed on the scores of a
set of students from their first grade
high school and undergraduation
the undergraduation score was the
dependent variable and first grade score
the independent variable
the value of correlation coefficient R
was calculated to be 0.29
and the correlation between
undergraduation scores and high school
scores was 0.45
this means the high school scores have
higher correlation compared to the first
grade scores
this States the performance of students
in high school is a better indicator of
their performance in undergraduation
than their performance in the first
grade although the correlation exists as
both the values of R are less than 0.85
it will be difficult to draw a straight
line on the scanner plot
in this screen we will learn about
regression although correlation gives
the direction of movement of the
dependent variable y as independent
variable X changes it does not provide
the extent of the movement of Y as X
changes
this degree of movement can be
calculated using regression
if a high percentage of variability in y
is explained By changes in x one can use
the model to write a transfer equation Y
is equal to f x and use the same
equation to predict future values of Y
given x and x given y
the output of regression on Y and X is a
transfer function equation that can
predict values of Y for any other value
of x transfer function is generally
denoted by F and the equation is written
as y equals to f of x
y can be regressed on one or more X's
simultaneously
simple linear regression is for 1X and
multiple linear regression is for more
than one X
the next screen will focus on key
concepts of regression
there are two key concepts of regression
transfer function to control Y and vital
X
click each concept to learn more
the output of regression is a transfer
function f of x
although the transfer function f of x
gives the degree of movement in y as X
changes it is not the correct transfer
function to control y as there may be a
low level of correlation between the two
the main thrust of regression is to
discover whether a significant
statistical relationship exists between
why and a particular X that is by
looking at P values based on regression
one can infer the vital X and eliminate
the unimportant X's
the analyze phase helps in understanding
if there is statistical relevance
between Y and X if the relevance is
established using metrics from
regression analysis one can move forward
with the tests
the simple linear regression or SLR
should be used as a statistical
validation tool in the beginning of this
phase
in this screen we will understand the
concept of simple linear regression
a simple linear regression equation is a
fitted linear equation and is
represented by the equation shown here
in this equation Y is the dependent
variable and X is the independent
variable
a is The Intercept of the fitted line on
the y-axis which is equal to the value
of y at x equal to zero
B is the regression coefficient or the
slope of the line and C is the error in
the regression model which has a mean of
zero
the next screen will focus on the least
squares method in simple linear
regression
with reference to the error mentioned
earlier if correlation coefficient of Y
and X is not equal to 1 meaning the
relation is not perfectly linear there
could be several lines that could fit in
the scatter plot
notice the two graphs displayed for the
same set of Five Points two different
types of lines are drawn and both of
them have errors error refers to the
points on the scatter plot that do not
fall on the straight line drawn the
second graph shows the y-intercept
statistical software like minitab fits
the line which has the least value of
Errors squared and added
as is clear from the graph error is the
distance of the point from the fitted
line
typically the data lies off the line
in perfect linear relation All Points
would lie on the line an error would be
zero the distance from the point to the
line is the error distance used in the
SSE calculations
let's understand SLR with the help of an
example in the next screen
consider the following example
suppose a farmer wishes to predict the
relationship between the amount spent on
fertilizers and the annual sales of his
crops he collects the data shown here
for the last few years and determines
his expected Revenue if he spends eight
dollars annually on fertilizers
he has targeted sales of 31 this year
the steps to perform simple linear
regression in Ms Excel are as follows
copy the data table on an Excel
worksheet
select all the data from B1 to C6 this
is assuming the years table appears in
cells A1 to A6
click insert and choose the plane
scatter chart